Und sicherlich auch zum Reisepass dann.
Und Spaß am Gerät.
Der digitale Reisepass ist das Thema des heutigen Chaosradios. 0331 70 97 110. Wie immer die Nummer der Fritzert-Line. Und ihr seid natürlich herzlich eingeladen mitzureden, mit zu diskutieren, vielleicht auch das eine oder andere Geheimnis auszuplaudern oder internes auszuplaudern. Wir haben heute schon einen Anrufer gehabt, der in der Bundesdruckerei arbeitet, da wo die Reisepasse hergestellt werden. Er hat ein paar interessante Sachen erzählt. Und vielleicht habt ihr ja auch die eine oder andere Frage zur Technik zu eben, wie hast du es eben so schön gesagt, sozialen Nebenwirkungen, Nebenwirkungen der Dinge, die da auf uns zukommen. Ab 1. November eben der neue digitale Reisepass mit einem RFID-Chip, mit biometrischen Daten, die darin gesammelt werden, auf das unser aller Leben sicherer werde. Nämlich wenn wir erstmal alle diesen Reisepass haben, dann wird garantiert kein Überfall mehr passieren in diesem Land.
Genau, wir würden gerne mal von euch wissen, glaubt ihr denn, dass so ein Reisepass mit biometrischen Merkmalen tatsächlich dazu beiträgt, sagen wir mal, uns sicherer zu machen gegen böse Terroristen und sonstige Kriminelle hilft. Das würden wir gerne mal wissen. Denkt ihr das hilft oder denkt ihr das ist eigentlich alles Unsinn?
0331 77 97 1 60 und bis ihr euch eine Meinung gebildet habt und die ihr hier am Telefon kundtut, sprechen wir mal mit Rick aus Hildesheim. Hallo Rick.
Hallo. Genau, genau und zwar inwieweit man die Dinge selber auslesen kann. Ich meine, in so einem normalen Analogenreise, das schlage ich auf, weil es was drin steht. Diesen Chip, da könnte sonst was reindrucken, ohne dass ich kontrollieren kann. Deswegen wäre es schon ganz interessant zu wissen, inwieweit das möglich ist, das auszulesen, um halt selber zu kontrollieren, was da über mich erfasst wird. Und übrigens, gerade für die Frage, ich denke mal nicht, dass das gegen Terroristen oder irgendwas wirklich, da wird es mit Sicherheit Möglichkeiten geben, auch die Dinge zu fälschen. Also das ist reine Illusion.
Ja oder vor allen Dingen, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf, einfach darauf zu scheißen. Weil wenn ich was in die Luft jagen will, dann jage ich das in die Luft. Egal, wer meine Fingerabdrücke vorher gekriegt hat.
Genau, gerade diese Selbstmordattentäter.
Vor allen Dingen hatten die Attentäter vom 11. September hatten alle gültige Reisepassen.
Insgesamt ist es auch viel einfacher, wenn du jemanden bei der Meldestelle bestichst und dem Geld gibst und dir dann halt einen echten Reisepass holst, aber unter einer falschen Identität zum Beispiel.
Genau, also, dass es die Möglichkeiten gab.
Und wenn es in Deutschland nicht geht, dann halt in ein anderes Land.
Eben.
Italien, da haben wir ja auch eben gehört, dass da der Euro-Schein nicht so besonders ist, der da herkommt.
Okay, wie werden hier ausgelesen, die Pässe?
Nee, nee, nicht wie. Wie habe ich selber die Möglichkeit, die auszulesen?
Genau, aber dazu muss ich erst mal wissen, wie sie ausgelesen werden. Und, wie gesagt, das passiert grundsätzlich über Funk, also über sogenannten RFID-Systemen, also Radio Frequency Identification, bedeutet also, da ist eine Funk-Schnittstelle, da ist ein Chip drinnen, der mit dem Lesegerät per Funk kommuniziert. Was sie gemacht haben, dafür müssen wir das BSI, was auch auf jeden Fall da ganz deutlich zu beigesteuert hat, das müssen wir mal ausdrücklich loben. Sie haben nämlich ein Feature eingeführt, das, wenn es so auch richtig funktioniert und machbar ist, auf jeden Fall schon mal ein ganz großes Problem löst, nämlich, dass man die Pässe nicht unbemerkt auslesen kann. Das heißt, man kann diese Reisepässe nicht mit einem Lesegerät außer Hosentasche durch die Hosentasche durch auslesen, so ohne weiteres. Zumindest nach jetzigem Stand der Technik.
Warum nicht?
Der Trick ist, die Daten auf dem Chip sind kryptographisch gesichert und der Chip kommuniziert erst, wenn ich mir einen Schlüssel erzeugt hab, einen kryptographischen Schlüssel, und diesen Schlüssel erzeug ich, indem ich optisch, das heißt also mit einem optischen Scanner, diese maschinenlesbare Zeile unten einlese. Da steht also drin die Reisepassnummer, Geburtsdatum und Ablaufdatum und aus dieser Zahlenreihe erzeugt das Lesegerät einen kryptographischen Schlüssel und erst damit mit diesem Schlüssel kann ich mit diesem Chip kommunizieren.
Das heißt, die Frage der Reichweite erübrigt sich damit auch?
Naja, nicht gänzlich.
Also das ist sozusagen der Idealfall erstmal. Wir kommen vielleicht später nochmal, oder kommen auf jeden Fall später nochmal dazu, was die Probleme dabei sein können, aber von der Grundidee her ist es schon mal total super und ein ganz großer Gewinn gegenüber normalen RFID-Chips, die jetzt dieses System nicht haben. Das ist auch eine deutsche Eigenart. Das ist auch eine Sache, die ist nicht verpflichtend. Aber zumindestens bei den deutschen Pässen können wir, wenn die Pässe so hergestellt werden, wie es in den übrigens auch öffentlichen Spezifikationen beschrieben ist und auch überall diskutiert wird, sehen wir das eigentlich von der Seite her erstmal entspannt, außer dass es möglicherweise auch ein bisschen zu einfach ist, diese Zahlenkolonnen zu raten. Da kommen wir später noch zu. Aber von der Grundidee her ist das erstmal ganz gut. Das heißt, du musst also diese Zahlenkolonne eingeben in das Software, in dein Computer und kannst dann erst mit dem Chip kommunizieren.
Also die Grundidee dahinter ist, dass nur jemand, der auch den Pass sehen kann, also den Inhalt des Passes sehen kann, auch in der Lage ist, diesen Chip auszulesen. Inwieweit es tatsächlich der Fall sein wird und inwieweit man zum Beispiel auch möglicherweise in der Lage ist, die Kommunikation eines Lesegerätes, dass halt diese Kombination kennt, zum Beispiel im Flughafen, über große Entfernungen abzuhören, ist noch nicht klar. Also da gibt es halt mehrere mögliche Angriffswege, die denkbar sind. Es wird sich vermutlich erst zeigen, sobald die ersten Pässe da sind, wie die konkrete Implementierung denn wirklich aussieht, ob da wirklich alle Details gedacht wurde.
Die Kommunikation kannst du auf jeden Fall abhören, weil irgendwie, da kann ich keine Ahnung daran hindern.
Aber sie ist einfach verschlüsselt.
Sie ist verschlüsselt, ist aber, also es ist halt irgendwie Krypto. Also es ist halt mit irgendwelchem Aufwand schon zu knacken.
Ist sie verhinderbar? Also kann ich, was weiß ich, wenn ich Alufolie drum wickele oder so?
Ja, aber nicht, wenn du halt irgendwie am Flughafen bist und halt deinen Ausweis dort vorzeigen musst, weil da bist du verpflichtet halt, den vorzuzeigen und dort wird auf jeden Fall Kommunikation stattfinden. Und wenn du dich dahinstellst, laut BSI-Angaben übrigens, bis zu 30 Meter des Passivabhörens. Das heißt, die stellen sich auf die andere Ecke von der Halle und irgendwie lesen die Kommunikation mit und können dann halt nachträglich die Daten daraus extrahieren.
Außerdem ist ein anderes Problem natürlich, dass man ziemlich frequent um Kopien seiner Personaldokumente gebeten wird, also zum Beispiel bei der Bank oder beim Vermieter und so weiter und so fort. Und auf diesen Kopien ist natürlich genau diese Zeile vorhanden. Das heißt also, es handelt sich, man würde es zu sagen, im Sprachbruch etwas sagen, um taktische Sicherheit.
Oder wieder der Fall zur Fußball-WM, also die Daten, die abgegeben werden mussten, um halt eine Karte zu bekommen, waren halt irgendwie genau die Daten, die als Verschlüsselung, also als Key für die Verschlüsselung eingesetzt werden.
Genau. Das Argument, warum man sich damit zufrieden gibt, sind, sagen wir mal, relativ niedrigschwellige Kryptographie zu verwenden, ist, dass die Daten, die dort auf dem Chip gespeichert werden, angeblich nur dem entsprechen, was man ohnehin hat, wenn man in diesen Reisepass guckt. Das heißt also, da soll dieser Chip in dieser Stufe erst mal nur verwendet werden, um eine zusätzliche Verifikation zu machen. Sprich, das ist halt Geburtsdatum, Name, Ausländerbehörde und das Bild drin. So wie wir zum Beispiel gestern gelernt haben, gehen die Daten, die da reingehen in diesen Chip tatsächlich darüber hinaus.
Immer noch mit Vorsicht, das ist halt noch nicht Standard, aber sie denken halt derzeit drüber nach.
Also es sieht halt so aus, als wenn da halt noch eine längliche Liste von Merkmalen erfasst wird. Zum Beispiel Holgi wurde dann, ich glaube, Bit 6 bekommen bei der Haarfarbe, das ist Glatze. Und ähnliche Dinge, die würden halt einfach mit erfasst werden und mit auf diesen Chip gehen, die halt ohne weiteres erst mal so nicht zu erschließen sind.
Genau deswegen möchte ich ja gerne das Ding selber auslesen. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, erst mal muss ich das Ding über ein Leser. Und dann, wie viel Frisbee entbindet das Ding?
Also du brauchst ein Lesegerät für den 14443 Standard, also das ist schon ein bisschen technisches Detail. Und du musst natürlich diese ganze Prozedur, die allerdings auch öffentlich beschrieben ist, dann nutzen. Es gibt vom BSI, die haben eine Referenzsoftware gemacht, da kannst du mal googeln, das nennt sich Golden Reader Tool, also Goldenes Leser Tool, und das ist sozusagen das, was die bei Vorführungen auf Messen und so was immer benutzen und auch um diese Systeme zu testen. Und es ist diese gesamte Umsetzung, technische Umsetzung dieser Infrastruktur, um diese Pässe zu lesen. Das heißt also diese sogenannte Basic Authentification oder Basic Access auf diese Sachen, die ohnehin im Pass enthalten sind, die sichtbar sind erst mal genau laut Spezifikation immer unter der Einschränkung.
Also das Problem dabei ist halt, das Golden Reader Tool ist nicht öffentlich verfügbar. Das heißt also, du musst dir dafür selber halt ein Tool schreiben, was dieser Spezifikation entspricht.
Was aber geht...
Also es geht noch viel einfacher, wenn du irgendwie keinen Hardware-Aufwand oder Software-Aufwand treiben willst, gehst du halt einfach zur Meldestelle und sagst irgendwie hier Auskunftspflicht, Artikel 16, Passgesetz. Und ich möchte jetzt gern wissen, welche Daten drauf geschweichert sind. Und Sie sind verpflichtet, dir dann halt genau den Inhalt...
Ja, müssen Sie haben.
Aber dann wäre interessant, ob Sie auch die zusätzlichen Daten rausbringen.
Genau, ob Sie wirklich die Datenfelder komplett rausrücken. Na ja, wer wie euch vielleicht denken könnt, irgendwie interessiert uns dieses Thema. Die Spezifikationen haben wir auch. Wir sind ja halt öffentlich und insofern müssen wir mal gucken. Vielleicht brauchen wir auch noch nicht zwingen, goldenen Relatur dafür. Okay, was man noch vielleicht erwähnen sollte, es gibt auf diesen Chips ja zwei Zugriffsebenen. Die eine haben wir schon gesprochen, ist der sogenannte Basic Access Control, die halt mit diesen Maschinen lesbaren Zeilen vom Pass funktioniert. Darüber hinaus gibt es halt noch den nächsten Schritt, wo denn biometrische Daten wie Fingerabdruck erfasst werden sollen. Die sind halt weitergehender und mit einem relativ ausgefällten kryptographischen System abgesichert, von dem einige Leute sagen, so ausgefeilt ist, dass unmöglich zu implementieren ist. Da ist dann wiederum aber so, dass die Schlüssel, mit denen man dann das Auslesen dieses Fingerabdrucks bewerkstelligen kann, zum Beispiel, um zu gucken, ob es wirklich seiner ist und wie der halt aussieht und so weiter und so fort, die sind nicht öffentlich und die werden auch nicht öffentlich sein. Das heißt also, da, an spätestens diesem Schritt, hat der Bürger dann nicht mehr die Möglichkeit, nachzuvollziehen, was auf diesem Chip wirklich alles gespeichert ist, sondern muss dann halt in seiner Meldestelle glauben. Das heißt also, da trägt man dann ein Stück Identifikationsdokument rum, wo die im Zweifel reinspeichern können, was sie wollen, ohne dass man irgendeine Chance hat, das nachzuvollziehen.
Wobei also vorgesehen ist oder eigentlich gemeinsamer Konsens ist, dass diese Reisepässe, die Chips auf den Reisepässen read-only sind. Das heißt also, nur beschreibbar sind. Das heißt, sie werden nur einmal bei der Ausstellung beschrieben und enthalten darüber hinaus.
Das ist Quatsch.
Wegen irgendwie dem Timestamp von dem letzten Auslesen.
Also das Problem ist halt, dass auch da, Entschuldigung, wir machen das ausgedrückt. Also es ist so, dass der ursprünglich war halt vorgesehen, dass diese Pässe in der Tat nur write-once sind. Das heißt also, dass die Meldestelle da einmal die Daten draufschreibt und dann ist Schluss. Nun ist aber mit dieser Fingerabdruckgeschichte ein Problem entstanden, nämlich bedingt durch die Eigenheiten des kryptographischen Systems, mit dem gesichert gestellt werden kann, dass nur ein autorisierter Leser in der Lage ist, diese Daten herauszulesen. Dann braucht man halt eine Struktur, wo ein Staat, ein Lieder, also so ein Lesegerät, autorisieren kann, diesen Fingerabdruck auszulesen. Da gibt es dann so eine mehrstufige Zertifikatsstruktur. Und am Ende entsteht das Problem, wie kann der Staat so einen Leser dazu zwingen, nicht mehr autorisiert zu sein? Also wie kann diese Autorisierung dem Leser wieder entzogen werden? Nehmen wir an, Deutschland verstreitet sich in 15 Jahren mit irgendwie hinterher beim Pakistan und möchte denen halt die Berechtigung entziehen, diese Fingerabdrücke auszulesen. Das ist halt schwierig. Und deswegen braucht man eine Möglichkeit, diesen Reisepassen da doch noch Daten hinzuzuschreiben. Und da wird dann halt, zumindest nach jetziger Planung, hingeschrieben, wann der letzte autorisierte Zugriff war auf diesen Reisepass. Und wenn der Reisepass dann einen Zugriff sieht, der halt mit einem komplett anderen Datum kommt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch. Also zum Beispiel einem Datum, was weiter zurückliegend ist, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass die Jungs da wo auch immer ein bisschen an ihrer Schraube gedreht haben, um halt die Reader weiter benutzen zu können mit Zertifikaten, die eigentlich schon expired sind.
Also prinzipiell gelten die Zertifikate für drei Monate und werden halt irgendwie alle drei Monate halt renewed.
Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist, dass die Grundidee ist, dass also nicht beliebig jeder Grenzbeamte irgendwelche Freitext-Kommentare an diesen Pass eintragen kann, wie hat sich heute aber nicht rasiert. So ist es eigentlich nicht gedacht.
Das sieht bekifft aus.
Genau. Das ist so nicht vorgesehen.
Aber wie gesagt, was die technische Sicherheit von diesen Chips betrifft, die wirklich sicher, die dann wirklich sind, kann man momentan eine Mutmaßung anstellen. Chipkarten sind halt einen langen Weg gegangen, was die Sicherheit betrifft, bedingt durch die PayTV-Industrie, die halt doch durchaus erkleckliche Mengen Lehrgeld dafür bezahlt hat, dass Chipkarten heute relativ sicher sind. Wie gut die Implementierung wirklich ist, wird sich dann natürlich sicherlich nicht zuletzt bei den Kosten entscheiden. Und insofern müssen wir halt mal gucken, wenn die ersten Pässe verfügbar sind, was da wirklich passiert.
Also von den Krypto-Algorithmen sieht das halt prinzipiell erst mal relativ gut aus, aber halt zu sagen, dass die in zehn Jahren halt nicht geknackt werden, ist eigentlich total erosorisch. Also gerade, was die Rechnerentwicklung derzeit ist.
Noch. Ist damit deine Frage beantwortet, Tobias?
Ja, na eigentlich schon. Meine Frage halt noch zu wissen, ist, ob noch Adressen gespeichert werden?
Nein, nicht die Reise passt nicht.
Ach so.
Das kommt dann erst später im Personalausweis.
Ah, aber es gab doch mal Gerüchte, dass Personalis auch diese Chipsysteme geben sollte.
Genau, das ist geplant. Das wünscht es sich zumindest sehr, Schili.
Wer auch immer der neue Innenminister wird, wird sicherlich auch nicht irgendwie viel dagegen haben.
Ja, wie ist das eigentlich? Die müssen doch in einer bestimmten Weise kodiert werden. Ich habe nur gerade das eingeschaltet, so wie ich es wahrscheinlich in die Mitte kriege. Die müssen irgendwie kodiert werden, die Dinger.
Was meinst du? Was genau kodiert?
Naja, man kann auch einfach so, sag ich mal, unverschüsselt Daten da drauf schreiben, Name, Geburtstag, was weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch Fingerabdruck und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, aber gerade eben genau.
Also die Daten selber sind unverschüsselt drauf, aber du kannst halt nur über die verschlüsselte Funkschnittstelle an die Daten rankommen.
Aber ich sag mal so, spinnen wir das Ganze jetzt mal weiter. Sagen wir mal, der Reiter hat das Git verloren. Und sag ich mal, irgendein Hacker hat das Ding jetzt halt in den Händen. Die Frage, kann er damit in irgendeiner Weise schabernackt betreiben oder auch nicht, mit diesen Chips, die halt drin sind.
Na er kann auf jeden Fall deine Daten auslesen, die da drauf gespeichert sind. Also zumindestens die Basics, also die Foto und die... Also die aufgedruckt sind. Aber zumindest das Bild ist schon deutlich bessere Qualität als das aufgedruckte Bild.
Nein. Nach jetzigem Stand der Erkenntnisse sind die Chips hinreichend gut, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Wie gesagt, ob das wirklich in der Realität der Fall ist und für die nächsten 10 Jahre der Fall ist, das können wir schlicht noch nicht beantworten.
Dazu muss man auch sagen, dass diese Pässe sind halt, denn auch da ist ein kompliziertes Stück Software drin. Also auf diesen Pässe läuft ein Betriebssystem ab auf der Karte. Da sind dann, weiß nicht, 100.000, vielleicht sogar Millionen Zahlen Code sogar auch verwendet worden. Okay, aber es kann beliebig kompliziert und unübersichtlich werden. Und haben wir mal so viel Vertrauen in die Leute, die das gemacht haben. Das sind alles richtig Leute.
Ja, und noch eine ganz große Zwischenfrage, würde es vom äußeren Format her bleiben, die so besetzt sind?
Es bleibt so ein Passbuch und der Chip geht in den Deckel. Da ist dann noch mal so ein Symbol drauf. Und man bekommt wohl noch so einen Merkzettel, damit man den nicht knicken, drauf rumkauen und so weiter.
Da vorne ist ein Symbol drauf, so ein komisches Chip-Symbol. Kannst du sehen auf der Seite www.bundesdruckerei.de und da zu den neuen Pässen, da haben die auch Bilder davon.
Aber zum Thema nicht knicken ist halt irgendwie das interessante wird, dass man halt durch knicken, also genau das, was man halt nicht tun sollte, den Chip so dermaßen kaputt kriegen kann, dass er halt nicht mehr funktioniert. Und der Pass selber bleibt dann aber weiterhin gültig.
Genau, das ist eine ganz wichtige Info. Diese Reiserpässe sind weiterhin gültig, auch wenn der Chip kaputt ist oder nicht mehr funktioniert. Allerdings, so hat uns das Bundesinnenministerium auf ein paar Fragen, die wir mal gestellt haben, geantwortet. Musst du dann mit einer verschärften Kontrolle rechnen.
Bis zum Ellbogen ist Freundschaft.
Dieses Detail, dass die Pässe weiter gültig sind, ist insofern interessant, als dass die Bundesdruckerei zurecht sagt, die deutschen Pässe sind eigentlich sicher. Sind halt die sichersten der Welt, sagen sie. Wahrscheinlich kann man das so auch stehen lassen. Nur verlassen sie sich am Ende dann doch wieder genau auf diese Sicherheit in den aufgedruckten Systemen, in den Hologrammen und so weiter und so fort.
Sie finden das als ein System einführend für mehrere Milliarden Euro, was im Endeffekt von denen, die es wirklich umgehen wollen, mit einer Mikrowelle oder 20 Minuten den Ausweisdeckel knicken.
Also Mikrowelle ist von abzuraten, weil Mikrowelle macht hässliche Panfischer.
Man sieht es, aber man kann ihn auch damit kaputt kriegen.
Also am besten ist dann einfach knicken.
Am besten ist knicken.
Also EMP wäre eine Option, aber da wären wir noch ein paar mehr Ideen.
Hören wir die heute noch?
Ein interessantes Bit ist diese 13, 56 MHz, die da auf den Chip kommuniziert mit dem Reader, sind interessanterweise genau die Frequenz, die bei weit verbreiteten Hochfrequenz Schweißgeräten verwendet wird. Und auch zum Beispiel bei Testgeräten für große Neonröhren, so Leuchtbuchstaben und so weiter und so fort, da werden auch genau diese Geräte verwenden. Da kommen so einige hundert Watt raus, wo es dann nicht so richtig drauf eingerichtet wird, da kommen normalerweise nur wenige Milliwattsendeleistungen an. Das heißt, wenn jemand mal so ein Hochfrequenzschweißgerät hat, dann ist sicherlich, den Reisepass sollte man nicht in die Nähe nehmen, wenn man noch möchte, dass der Chip-in ja noch funktioniert.
Und man sollte natürlich auch nicht neben dem Flughafen Lerida irgendwie so ein Schweißgerät betreiben.
Vielen Dank für diese Sicherheitsinhalte.
Wir können ja auf dem Kongress mal einen Workshop dazu machen, da dürften die ersten Leute ja schon die neuen Pässe haben.
Das stimmt allerdings. Wir hatten eine Frage gestellt, die Frage an euch Höhende lautete, glaubt ihr denn eigentlich, dass das das Leben sicherer macht, dass wir also alle viel besser davor gefight sein werden, weiß der Geier, Überfällen ausgesetzt zu sein oder terroristischen Anschlägen oder was gibt es denn eigentlich noch? Was sagen sie denn noch, wozu das gut ist?
Polizei übergefahren?
Nein, nein, das war wieder was anderes.
Also wir hatten Terroristen im Asylbewerber, in Wirtschaftsförderung, äh, nein, Moment.
Haben wir da eine Hörer, die was zu sagen haben?
Ja, 0331 70 97 110. Glaubt ihr, dass es das Ganze sicherer macht oder glaubt ihr, dass das alles nur eine Farce ist? Daniel aus Kreuzberg. Was denn? Ja, Daniel.
Jo, also ich hab halt die Vermutung, dass die Regierung bloß so wegen Einnahmen, mit Gründen so macht.
Also du glaubst nicht, dass es das sicherer macht?
Ähm, naja nicht unbedingt. Also ich hab ja schon eine Weile zugehört und wenn ihr sagt, die sind halt schon ziemlich gut von der Qualität, äh Qualität.
Na die interessante Frage ist doch, aber glaubst du denn, dass es irgendwie ein Sicherheitsgewinn für dich persönlich bringt, dass der Staat deine Fingerabdrücke hat?
Ja Daniel, alles klar. Danke für deinen Anruf dann mal. Jo, ähm jetzt müsste eigentlich dieses Gerät automatisch den nächsten dran genommen haben, hat es aber gar nicht, weiß auch nicht warum. Komisch. Äh Axel?
Ja, hallo?
Hallo, glaubst du, dass es das sicherer macht?
Keineswegs. Keineswegs. Ich halte das eigentlich für einen groß angelegten Angriff auf die persönliche Informationsfreiheit, was dort passiert. Ich halte diese ganze Diskussion um Terrorismusschutz für relativ weit hergeholt. Es ist ein netter Anlass, das mal wieder auf die Tagesordnung zu bringen. Wie ihr ja vorhin schon sagt, es nicht umsonst hat schon mal vor 30 Jahren ein gewisser Herr gefordert, die Fingerabdrücke der ganzen Bundesregierung Herr Bundesrepublik zu speichern.
Also es war auch sehr interessant zu sehen, wie schnell die ganzen Gesetze aus den Schubladen gezogen wurden nach dem 11. September.
Die lagen da glaube ich schon relativ lange.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, Sie müssten doch einfach sagen, wir machen das. Also wir würden jetzt gerne von allen die Fingerabdrücke haben. Das hat Buback, also Generalbundesanwalt damals gesagt, weil er gesagt hat, weil der Generalbundesanwalt, dessen primäres Interesse ist die Strafverfolgung. Das heißt, er sagt, ich will alle Fingerabdrücke haben, damit ich hinterher ganz einfach gucken kann, wer war zu der Zeit an dem Tatort oder wer war überhaupt am Tatort. Da können wir schon mal vorher ausfiltern, was da ist. Warum, frage ich mich und frage ich euch, geht ein unser Bundesinnenminister nicht hin und sagt das einfach. Sagt einfach, wir wollen hinterher, dann ist es wenigstens glaubhaft.
Das lässt er den Bund der deutschen Kriminalbeamten sagen. Die Gewerkschaft der Polizei. Die Gewerkschaft der Polizei, die haben sich zwei Tage, nachdem es irgendwie bekannt war, dass es kommt mit den Pässen, hingestellt und sagen, ja also wir brauchen jetzt aber auch ganz dringend eine zentrale Datenbank, sonst macht das überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Also ich meine, was soll denn der Quatsch, wenn die Fingerabdrücke zwar auf den Ausweisen sind, aber wieder keinen Zugriff haben. Wir brauchen jetzt hier eine digitale, eine zentrale Datenbank, Speicherung von diesen ganzen Daten, sonst bringt das alles überhaupt nichts. Und das ist rausgeworfenes Geld. Klar, aus deren Sicht ist das natürlich ein verständliches Anliegen.
Wie ist es aus deiner Sicht, Axel?
Ja, das ist eine Sache, die mich doch ungemein erschreckt, weil das von dem, sagen wir mal, Verdichtigkeit oder von dem Verdacht auf eine Straftat doch wesentlich wegführt dahin, dass ich tatsächlich relativ viel von jedem Bürger speichere. Und wer sagt mir denn, dass dann wirklich nur noch die Polizei auf diese zentrale Datenbank Zugriff hat? Wer sagt mir denn, dass da nicht auch andere Leute und dabei habe ich primär zuerst erst mal relativ große Unternehmen im Hinterkopf, die dann irgendwann mal sagen, ja, ich möchte aber jetzt zur Aufklärung irgendeines internen Problemes mal Zugriff auf diese Datenbank haben und möchte wissen, ob der und der dann und dann an der und der Tastatur gesessen hat. Und dafür brauche ich jetzt dringend die Daten, weil meine interne Sicherheit sehr stark gefährdet die Daten aus dieser Datenbank und vergleiche das mit allen meinen Mitarbeitern ab, die ich habe.
Also genau das ist irgendwie nach der Einführung.
Entschuldigung, ganz kurz nochmal. Auf die Art und Weise, da er schließlich die Daten aller Mitarbeiter braucht, kriegt er innerhalb kürzester Zeit einen Datenbankauszug all seiner Mitarbeiter. Und dann hat das Unternehmen diese Datenbank all seiner Mitarbeiter mit allen Finger abdrückt. Und dann liegen die Daten nicht nur zentral gespeichert, sondern irgendwo auf einem gut abgeschirmten Firmenrechner.
Also da muss man jetzt erstmal sagen, wie laut Gesetzeslage gibt es, wird es keine zentrale Datenbank geben, jedenfalls nach aktueller Gesetzeslage. Ja natürlich. Und selbst, also wenn es die geben würde, dann gibt es halt immer noch den Fall, dass halt nur gewisse Behörden auf diese Datenzugriff entnehmen können. Also theoretisch darf der Chef nicht kommen und sagen wie, ja ich hab da irgendwie einen Diebstahl in meiner Firma und ich hätte jetzt gerne mal irgendwie alle Fingerabdruckdaten. Also soweit natürlich immer nur die Theorie.
Das ist aber glaube ich eine sehr wohlwollend sehende Theorie.
Na so steht es halt derzeit im Gesetz. Also ich meine, hängt drauf an, wie du dich irgendwie, was du von diesen Gesetzen hilfst.
Die Geschichte zeigt ja, dass der Daten, die Datengier, wenn sie dann einmal verhandelt sind, die Daten doch immer findet. Insbesondere wenn es um irgendwelche Ermittlungen geht. Also ich denke mal, nach dem ersten terroristischen Anschlag in Deutschland fällt da einfach so dermaßen die Schranke her.
Also das wollte ich vorhin noch irgendwie anführen mit der Maut. Also ich meine, die haben einfach mal das System aufgebaut und irgendwie zwei Tage später kam die Polizeibeamte und meinten oh ihr habt dann so ein tolles System, wir haben hier irgendwie gerade ein Verdächtigen, Flüchtigen und wir würden gerne mal die Daten haben, obwohl es halt irgendwie trotzdem explizit vorher gesagt wurde, die Daten irgendwie kriegt die Polizei nicht.
Hat sie die denn gekriegt?
Im Endeffekt nicht, weil dann nochmal glücklicherweise noch eine kleine Gesetzesänderung nachgeschoben worden ist im Dezember.
Ist vor allem publik geworden rechtzeitig.
Ja, wo dann gesagt wird, ne, also diese Daten gibt es nicht, Punkt. Aber hinterher hat man dann auch gleich wieder versucht, irgendwie da wieder drum rumzukommen. Also diese Begehren ist einfach ganz doll da.
Und wenn es die Polizei nicht kriegt, irgendwie Geheimdienste kriegen sie.
Und beim nächsten Mal ist man da nicht so unvorsichtig, das so öffentlich zu fragen. Und dann kommt man dann vielleicht auch an die Daten. Dann wird man einfach genügend Mühe haben, die Öffentlichkeit oder genügend Mühe investieren, die Öffentlichkeit so weit wie möglich außen vorzuhalten.
Natürlich.
Und das ist die Sache, die das meiner Ansicht nach noch viel schlimmer macht. Man erfährt es einfach nicht.
Ein ganz großes Problem, was ich persönlich noch sehe, ist, dass wir vielleicht keine zentrale Speicherung der Daten bekommen. Das heißt, sie sind bei den Meldestellen nach wie vor dezentral hinterlegt. Aber ich sehe, dass wir möglicherweise eine sogenannte zentrale Indexdatei bekommen. Die haben wir jetzt schon, das ist die sogenannte europäische Terrorismus-Datei, eine Indexdatei. Die muss man sich vorstellen einfach wie Google. Im Internet ist ja auch alles dezentral hinterlegt. Es gibt ja keinen dezentralen Server, sondern alles liegt halt irgendwo im Internet verstreut. Aber um es zu finden, habe ich halt Google. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt jemanden suche, dann benutze ich einfach diese Suchmaschine. Und da könnte möglicherweise ein Stupfloch geschaffen werden, dass wir dann letztendlich doch wieder zu einem zentralen...
Das Gesetz schließt doch explizit die Vernetzung von dezentralen Datenpunkten aus.
Klar, nur das wäre ein Weg, wie man das Ganze ohne jetzt großen Aufständen der Bevölkerung vielleicht oder in den Medien zu machen. Sagt, naja, wenn wir ehrlich sind, halten die Medien doch ohnehin still.
Das halte ich irgendwie nur für ein physikalisches Hindernis.
Das ist ein rechtliches, ein juristisches Hindernis.
Ja, bei juristischen Hindernissen bin ich sehr vorsichtig. Die fallen schneller als alles andere. Und wie gesagt, wie ob die Daten nun wirklich an einer zentralen Stelle a la Flensburg lagern oder ob ich sie wirklich auf verteilten Systemen, was ja im Endeffekt noch eher die sicherere Lösung darstellt, also für die Datenspeicherung sichere Lösung darstellt. Das ist doch eigentlich nur ein physikalisches Problem.
Das spielt keine Rolle, ja.
Wobei wir natürlich schon in Deutschland auch einen guten Grund haben, warum wir diese dezentrale Speicherung haben und keine zentrale Speicherung. Das ist einfach eine Erfahrung, die wir im Dritten Reich gelernt haben.
Entschuldigung, aber damals gab es das Reichssicherheitshauptamt und genau so was wie das Reichssicherheitshauptamt hat sich Angela Merkel, die designierte Kanzlerkandidatin oder was auch immer sie demnächst werden wird, vor einigen Jahren hier für dieses Land gewünscht. Das hieß nur anders.
Aber das ist das Thema, das wir jetzt haben, mit diesen dezentralen Meldestellen und keine zentrale Datei und keine persönlichen Kennziffer. Das ist einfach eine Grundidee, dass man es eigentlich nicht will, die gesamte Bevölkerung zentral erfasst zu haben.
Die Frage ist, man nicht will, ist eine etwas schwammige Formulierung. Um es mal ganz präzise zu formulieren, das geht zurück auf das Volkszählungsurteil, in dem genau diese Dinge verboten wurden. Insbesondere das Verbot einer Personenkennziffer wurde dort festgelegt. Interessanterweise ist aber genau die Ablage von biometrischen Merkmalen in numerischer Form auf so einem Chip eine nicht veränderliche Personenkennziffer. Das heißt also, da gibt es sicherlich nochmal juristisches Neuland, was zu erforschen ist vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht, inwieweit halt die Ablage biometrischer Daten auf diesem Reisepass überhaupt grundgesetzkonform ist. Meiner Meinung nach sind es nämlich nicht. Und zwar vor allen Dingen, weil diese biometrischen Merkmale unveränderlich sind. Das heißt also, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, an irgendeiner Stelle diese Merkmale wieder loszuwerden. Und sie sind zugänglich und sie können auch im Zweifel benutzt werden, um eine Datenmangel zu indexieren. In diesem Fall, denke ich mal, ist dann halt zu schauen, ob das Bundesverfassungsgericht bereit ist, sozusagen sein altes Urteil aufrechtzuerhalten und sich dann doch erheblichen internationalen Spaß zu gönnen. Oder ob sie dann halt einknicken und zu sagen, okay, naja, es können keine Ziffer.
Das Problem ist, dass sie halt vorher genau das, also sie konnten vorher, es kann vorher keine Klage eingereicht werden, sondern erst halt nach der Einführung. Und wenn das System halt einmal steht, dann wird das Bundesverfassungsgericht wahrscheinlich schon sich überlegen, da was gegen zu sagen.
Dann wird das auch nicht mehr gekippt werden.
Genau.
Ja, es ist eine ganz eindeutige Ziffer, die ist sogar eindeutiger als eine irgendwie verteilte Person kennen soll, so wie sie früher zu DDR-Zeiten mal existierte.
Also mit DDR-Zeiten ist halt auch noch so ein Punkt. Also nicht mal zu DDR-Zeiten eine flächendeckende Fingerabdruckerfassung der Bevölkerung.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Wie gesagt, es gab eine Person kennen soll, die nach relativ einfachen Kriterien erstellt worden ist. Da war also neben dem Datum, das Geschlecht, das Geburtsjahrtausend und der ausstellende Kreis kodiert und mehr auch nicht.
Ja, aber es war veränderbar. Das ist eben das Wesentliche. Ich meine, sowas hast du ja heute auch. Du hast heute auch eine Sozialversicherungsnummer, aber die ist auch änderbar.
Die ist theoretisch änderbar, wohingegen die biometrischen Daten natürlich wirklich unveränderbar sind und demzufolge ganz streng auf eine Person zugewiesen sind und das also nicht nur eine eindeutige, sondern eine eindeutige Abbildung gibt und das ist relativ erschreckend. Und wie gesagt, ich bin also keineswegs der Meinung, dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise die Sicherheit erhöht. Denn welche Sicherheit soll es denn erhöhen?
Axel, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ihr hört das Chaosradio 106. Es geht um den elektronischen Reisepass, der ab dem 1. November eingeführt werden wird. Und gleich reden wir weiter vorher. Da hören wir Nachrichten.
Chaosradio at ccc.de ist unsere Mailadresse.
Ja Chaosradio 106. Ich hätte ja schon mal gesagt, wir hören Nachrichten.
Am 7.
Oktober im Fritz Club im Postbahnhof.
Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Das exklusive Fritz Radio Konzert.
Am 12. Oktober im Nicolaisal Potsdam.
Am 13.
Oktober in der Columbia Halle Berlin.
Am 25.
Oktober auch in der Columbia Halle Berlin.
Fritz im Oktober.
Fritz vom RBB.
Fünf nach halb zwölf.
Fritz Info.
Bei Mercedes in Deutschland fällt fast jeder zehnte Arbeitsplatz weg. Daimler Chrysler will bei Mercedes im Laufe eines Jahres insgesamt 8.500 Jobs streichen. Der Konzern will den Stellenabbau vor allem durch Abfindungen erreichen. Der Bremer Bürgermeister Henning Scherff hat seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Scherff sagte, er werde in wenigen Wochen 67 und wolle noch ein Leben nach der Arbeit führen. Scherff wählte für seinen Rücktritt etwa die Mitte der Legislaturperiode. Union und SPD haben ihr zweites Sondierungsgespräch für eine mögliche Koalition geführt. Bundeskanzler Schröder sagte danach, er gehe davon aus, dass beide Seiten eine stabile Regierung für vier Jahre erreichen könnten. Es sei heute um Inhalte und nicht um Personalfragen gegangen. CDU-Chefin Merkel bezeichnete das Gespräch als ernsthaft und konstruktiv. Zum Sport in der Fußball Champions League trenden sich am Abend Schalke 04 und der AC Mailand 2 zu 2 unentschieden. In der Nacht erwarten uns so gut wie keine Schauer und nur wenige Wolken. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen 9 und 6 Grad. Morgen ist es meistens wolkiger und kann immer mal wieder regnen. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 13 bis 17 Grad. AC nördlicher Berliner Regenhafe landrichtung Schwaneweg zwischen Kreuz Oranienburg und Birkenwerder gibt es eine Wanderbaustelle. Die linke Spur ist dort gesperrt. A10 westlicher Berliner Regenhafen landrichtung Werder zwischen Tankstelle Wolfslake West und Falkensee wird die Fahrbahn erneuert. Die linke Fahrstreifen ist dort gesperrt. Ansonsten überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario. Ich abmüse mich immer über das Wort Wanderbaustelle. Entschuldigung. Danke Mario. Sechs Minuten nachher zwölf.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Am letzten Mittwoch im Monat das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Heute das Thema im Chaos Radio 106, der elektronische Reisepass. Demnächst neu in Ihrem Bundesgebiet. Chaos Radio 106, es geht um den elektronischen Reisepass. Sie haben eine Mail gekriegt. Eigentlich ist unsere E-Mail Adresse chaosradio.ccc.de, was aber auch ankommt und ab und zu auch mal gecheckt wird, ist holger.klein.fritz.de oder rbb-online.de. Und genau darin hat Theresa eine Mail geschickt. Und die schreibt, ihr habt gerade gesagt, dass es im Nahen Osten mehrere Länder gibt, die biometrische Datenerkennung schon einsetzen, vor allen Dingen für Nichtstaatsbürger im Lande. Welche Länder sind das denn? Denn ich würde, also sie, Theresa, würde eigentlich annehmen, dass Israel da ganz schnell mit dabei wäre, aber sie wohnt schon seit zwei Jahren da, ohne überhaupt irgendwo erfasst worden zu sein.
Also, ah, schön, dass wir auch in Israel gehört werden. Ich weiß jetzt von den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten, die sowas machen und soweit ich weiß, arbeiten noch mehrere von den anderen kleineren Golfanreinerstarten daran, solche Systeme einzuführen. Da geht es halt immer nur um ein paar Tausend Leute. Es sind halt keine riesigen Millionen Systeme, die da verwendet werden. Ansonsten war da noch dieser Detail mit der, ja genau, was wir immer gesagt haben, war Reisepässe zehn Jahre gültig. Es gibt da ein Detail, was gerade für diese Hörergruppe hier, für Fritz besonders interessant ist. Leute, die jünger sind als 25, bekommen nur einen fünf Jahre gültigen Reisepass, weil man offensichtlich davon ausgeht, dass sich die, das Aussehen und so weiter und so fort noch signifizierter verändert, wenn man jünger als 25 ist. Das heißt also, wenn ihr morgen losgeht, euch einen neuen Reisepass holen und noch jünger seid als 25 Jahre, dann bekommt ihr leider nur einen fünfjährigen Reisepass.
Dafür ist es auch ein bisschen billiger.
Das ist ja aber super. Dann ist das ja alles gar nicht so schlimm. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer dieser Sendung, um mitzureden beziehungsweise Fragen zu stellen und wo haben wir denn?
Hallo? Jetzt hat Holger seine Telefonanlage verbummelt.
Jetzt hab ich meine Telefonanlage verbummelt. Früher war besser, früher ging es intuitiver. Christian, hallo.
Hallo.
Schließ los, du bist dran. Du hast eine Frage.
Ja, ich hätte vielleicht was sagen, warum er jetzt vielleicht eingeführt wird oder warum Schli das jetzt macht oder wer dahinter steckt. Also ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass es das einfachste für ihn ist. Ich sag mal, da wir uns schon nicht am Krieg beteiligt haben und die Leute, die Terroristen immer dummerweise in Deutschland waren, hat er gesagt, muss man irgendwas machen, was irgendwo gut ankommt. Und ein Reiseplatz ist eh da, also wird er nur modifiziert. Er hat ja nichts Neues gemacht, sondern nur etwas geändert. Da ist die Diskussion sowieso schon mal nicht so groß. Ich sag mal, über Datensicherheit regen sich eh alle Leute auf und die meisten verstehen gar nicht, worum es geht, sondern hören nur, es wird sicherer, ist also alles in Ordnung und tun man sich nicht weiter drum. Also denke ich mal, es ist für ihn das Einfachste, das so zu machen, weil er nichts Neues machen muss. Und er ändert nur was ab, hat ein bisschen Diskussion, die ächzt dann bald ab und das Thema ist durch.
Echt eine interessante Theorie.
Interessant ist ja dabei das Spielchen, was dabei auch gemacht wurde bei der Argumentation, dass also der Chile sich hinstellt und sagt, naja, es ist auf EU-Ebene beschlossen worden und die EU-Ebene sagt, naja, die Amerikaner wollten das so. Und so, jetzt hinterher wird es jetzt keiner gewesen sein und diese Pässe sind da.
Ja, also da wird nachher auch keiner mehr nachfragen, wer es nun gesagt hat oder wer nicht. Durch, jeder sagt, der andere hat es gesagt. Das heißt, die Amis sind dann, sagen okay, die Deutschen machen das, machen wir es auch. Die Nächsten sagen, wir machen es dann auch. Und dann schreien nachher alle, wenn die das machen, müssen wir es ja auch, das wird EU-weit eingeführt.
Bis einer weint, bis einer weint.
Genau, das interessante dabei ist, dass die Amerikaner genau die Letzten sind, diese Pässe einführen, weil nämlich die sind, ist die ganze Technik noch ein bisschen obskur und die wollen das alles noch gar nicht und die haben jetzt irgendwie auch Privacy-Probleme, weil die nämlich genau diese Techniken, die wir in Deutschland vorgesehen haben, haben die nicht vorgesehen und die haben jetzt erst mal gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ne, also Moment.
Die werden aber ein Problem bekommen, wenn das tatsächlich hier eingeführt wird, wenn dann die Amerikaner aus der Welt, kann ja nicht sein, dass die einen höheren Standard haben als wir und schon werden dann die ersten kommen und sagen, dann ist es wesentlich einfacher, dann kommt nämlich ein Busch und sagt, dann müssen wir ja auch, weil die Europäer haben es ja auch.
Ach na, ich glaub nicht, dass die Amerikaner damit argumentieren, wenn ihre Stromversorgung funktioniert ja auch nicht.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist für ihn das einfachste Gemüse, so was zu machen. Hätte er jetzt irgendein Gesetz gemacht, irgendwas ganz Neues oder so, um die Amis zu beruhigen, wäre die Diskussion wesentlich größer gewesen hier. Also das ist sehr einfach. Die Mautgeschichte, da ging es ja auch, ob Pkw-Maut kommt, Kontrolle und Strafzettel automatisch, haben wir ja auch gerade gehabt. Das heißt, es geht so in einem Rutsch weiter.
Was macht eigentlich die Pkw-Maut?
Nächstes Jahr wieder.
Da ist der HDAC davor.
Das ist der einzige Verein, der die Bundesrepublik noch in Gauen aufteilt. Naja, also noch irgendjemand macht das. Wer war das denn noch? Also der HDAC und noch irgendjemand für einen Mann.
Ja, ich denke, es ist einfach einfach. Weil die Studie läuft so. Es geht immer um Datensicherheit. Und dann kommt eben noch ein Teil dazu. Das heißt, es regen sich, weil ich behaupte einfach mal, der größte Teil der Leute, die kriegen den neuen Pass, die nehmen den neuen Pass, wissen gar nicht, was halt passiert. Und das Thema ist durch und regen sich höchstens auf, dass er teurer ist.
Also ich glaube, in dem Umblick, wo die Leute Fingerabdrücke abliefern müssen, da wird einigen Leuten doch nochmal die Muffe gehen.
Das hat LALore gesehen.
So Fingerabdruck ist halt so richtig tief drin.
Unveränderbar sogar.
Und das ist einfach dieses Szenario, du stehst halt irgendwie, du siehst es halt, du bist halt irgendwie in Handschellen, irgendwie in einem Raum mit irgendwie die Tischlampe ins Gesicht geblendet und Fotos auf so einem komischen Stuhl werden von dir gemacht und du musst halt irgendwie in so einem komischen schwarzen Pampen diese Fingerabdrücke. Das ist so dieses, vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist jetzt leider genau nicht so, weil die Technik umgestellt haben, es ist halt schon ein bisschen sauberer und du musst halt nur auf den Sensor packen und keine schwarzen Finger mehr. Also sie haben da schon so ein bisschen dran gedacht, dass diese Assoziation nicht entsteht.
Wenn es dann noch 10 Euro Rabatt gibt, dann ist es noch einfacher.
Genau, das ist ein Rabatt, im besten so ein Kaffeemärkchen oder so. So unmittelbar. Der Urs hat eine Frage.
Jo, und zwar ist eben im IRC die Frage aufgetaucht, damit will ich noch mal Werbung machen für den Kanal Rautekhaosradio und Freenode. Wenn jetzt der Staat, bzw. nicht nur mein Staat, sondern auch irgendwelche beliebigen anderen Staaten Zugriff auf meine, sagen wir Fingerabdruckinformationen haben, wie ist das denn für mich, wenn ich da meine persönliche Hardware mit sichern möchte, wenn ich mein Laptop damit sichern möchte? Eigentlich werden diese Daten ja eigentlich für mich dann völlig, völlig unnützt, wenn ich die vor meinem Start, aus welchem Grund auch immer, sichern möchte.
Naja, das Problem ist halt, dass du dann jedes Mal oder zumindest, auf deinem Notebook, den Key, der aus der Maschine, die besogen generiert wird, abspeichern und könntest dann halt mit dem FID Reader sozusagen nicht authentifizieren.
Ich meine jetzt gar nicht mal, dass ich den Ausweis zur Authentifizierung nutzen will.
Der Start hat deine Fingerabdrücke.
Ich habe ganz normal sowieso von meiner Hardware gesichert, über irgendwelche Biometrie und jetzt will plötzlich der Start, dass ich ihm meine Daten gebe und dass zum Beispiel die USA, wenn ich da einreise, dann auch meine Daten habe und vielleicht Aserbaidschan und Georgian auch.
Das ist mal ganz ehrlich, aber wenn du deine Hardware mit Fingerabdruck sichern bist du doch schön blöd.
Ja, das mach ich natürlich nicht, aber dann wäre das natürlich gleich wieder, was ja vorher jetzt verboten war, ein interessanter Punkt.
Aber das Problem ist doch, dass die meisten Consumer, sie werden ihre Hardware mit Fingerabdruck sichern.
Der große Vorschub kommt auf jeden Fall in allen möglichen Lebensbereichen. Es gibt jetzt schon Videotheken und der Zoo von Hannover und wo auch immer und wenn es erstmal in den Pässen ist, dann denken auch alle, oh, es ist ja toll, funktioniert und dann werden sie es überall insitzen. Aber die interessante Frage ist eigentlich eher andersrum und zwar, wo könntest du jetzt schon deine Fingerabdruck abgeben und wie sicher sind die Daten nur dort? Also es gibt jetzt Videotheken, wo du deinen Fingerabdruck abgeben kannst, hier landet auf einem komischen kruden Windows-Rechner, der wahrscheinlich noch am Netz hängt und halt genau dann der andere Weg, dass dann halt irgendwie die Sicherheit des Passes halt auch wieder heruntergesetzt wird, weil deine Daten halt, also dein Fingerabdruck irgendwo rumfliegen und sie halt auch nicht wirklich ausgewechselt werden können. Also du hast halt nur zehn Finger und wenn halt alle zehn Finger irgendwie einmal geleakt sind, dann kannst du maximal deine Füße noch nehmen und dann ist aber auch vorbei.
Aber du hinterlässt dann den Fingerabdruck ja auch mehrere tausendmal pro Tag.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt meine Fingerabdrücke einfach mal nehmen würde, selbst hochqualitiv einscannen und im Netz hochladen, z.B. in irgendeinem anonymen Fingerabdruck Pool, dann könnte ich doch auf diese Art und Weise sie sozusagen unnütz machen für solche Spielereien von irgendwelchen Startsendungen, die jederzeit das fälschen könnte.
Haben wir auch schon mehrfach dran irgendwie gedacht, das mal zu tun. Also sinnvoll ist das wahrscheinlich nur, wenn man es in Verbindung mit der Anleitung zum Fälschen macht.
Da staunt der Fachmann und der Laie wundert sich. Erklärt mir mal, wie das geht. Also einen anonymen Pool hochladen, das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Also die Idee ist, dass du quasi eine Webseite machst, wo einfach eine Million oder 100.000 Fingerabbrücke sind und die kannst du dir einfach als Bild runterladen. Und dann zum Beispiel, das haben wir auf der Webseite www.ccc.de biometrie haben wir das beschrieben, wie man das machen kann, wie man viele Sensoren damit überlisten kann. Das heißt, du druckst es ja aus auf einem Laserdrucker, machst ein bisschen so Holzleim, eine spezielle Holzleimmischung und klebst es dir dann mit Maskenkleber auf den Finger und schon hast du eine neue Identität und diese Vorlagen dafür, wenn man die einfach massenweise macht, dann ist es sozusagen kein Merkmal.
Das würde den Beweis, dass ein Fingerabdruck einer Person zugehört ist, massiv einschränken. Das heißt, der Richter würde eigentlich sehen, da sind zwar Fingerabdrücke am Tatort, aber dein Fingerabdruck ist schon 100-fach im Netz und mit Anleitung, wie man ihn einfach nachmachen kann und deswegen ist es halt nicht mehr als Beweis zulässig.
Die Frage, ob wir das natürlich haben wollen und vorantreiben wollen, weil dann kommt es natürlich sofort, dann ist DNA, Proben-DNA-Analysen sind dann irgendwie diskret.
Ja, aber DNA ist nicht eindeutig. Also, eineige Zwillinge haben identische DNA, aber unterschiedliche Fingerabdrücke. Super Idee.
Also, das ist gar nicht so unrealistisch. Stimmt. Also, bei DNA ist es ja eher so der Fall, dass man es sehr schwer ist, DNA von Tatorten zu verschwinden zu lassen, was halt relativ einfach ist, einfach mal von 1000 Leuten dort DNA auszusetzen und dann praktisch damit deine eigene Spur zu verwischen.
Vielleicht noch mal was anderes zu den biometrischen Daten und wer die denn überhaupt auslesen kann. Das war auch eine der Fragen, die wir an die Bundesregierung gestellt haben, die, wie eigentlich alle anderen Fragen auch extrem ausweichend beantwortet worden sind, um nicht zu sagen gar nicht. Die Frage war, welche Länder denn eigentlich jetzt Zugriff auf diese Biometriedaten, also die erweiterten Biometriedaten, sprich Fingerabdruckdaten, bekommen sollen. Im Rahmen der Einführung der Planung für die Pässe hieß es halt, naja, es wird dann halt so vertrauenswürdige Länder geben, die dann in den bilateralen Abkommen, das heißt also ihr dürft unsere lesen und wir dürfen dafür eure lesen, denn diese Fingerabdruckdaten auslesen dürfen. Und für uns wäre es natürlich immer ganz interessant zu wissen, welche Länder werden das dann sein? Wird das die USA sein, China, Aserbaidschan, wer auch immer, vielleicht nur innerhalb der EU, innerhalb Schengen. Da scheint es aber bisher auch keine Idee zu geben in der Bundesregierung.
Also was dabei interessant ist, dass es dann natürlich die ganzen Krypto-Verfahren, die da irgendwie zum Einsatz kommen, also das heißt eine PKI, also eine Private Key Infrastructure, die muss natürlich irgendwie betrieben werden. Und wer sich damit auskennt, der weiß, dass ab ein paar tausend Leuten das irgendwie echt schwierig wird, die wirklich umzusetzen. Und bei 80 Millionen Deutschen, 340 Millionen Europäern, ist das eigentlich total aussichtslos, das wirklich irgendwie machen zu wollen.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, aber ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass diese Reisepässe tatsächlich selbst nur Symmetris-Verschlüssel haben. Zwar jeder Key sein eigen Individuellen, aber dass es halt mit Smartcard-Technologie noch sehr schwer ist, das tatsächlich publikieren Intersektor draufzubringen.
Nein, die Chips müssen entweder ECC unterstützen oder RSA. Also die beiden Verfahren sind zwingend vorgegeben. Eines von den beiden muss unterstützt werden und damit machen sie halt ein richtiges Public Key PKI System.
Danke Urs und gute Nacht. Eine Frage aus Essen. Martin.
Ja, hallo.
Ja, ich hab so eine kleine technische Frage.
Möchtest du vielleicht den Hörer in die Hand nehmen?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Also ich hab so eine technische Frage, die geht so in die Richtung Wirtschaft. Und zwar, also folgendes Szenario wäre das möglich. Ich geh mit meinem Personalsize bei Carstadt einkaufen. Die haben so ein RFID-Reader. Und die Verschlüsselung lässt ja nicht zu, oder die Kryptographie lässt ja nicht zu, dass jetzt mein Name ausgelesen wird. Richtig. Aber ist das nicht möglich, dass so funktioniert, dass auch derzeit im Internet Cookie abgelegt wird und so was wie eine Konstante dann doch lesbar ist?
Das war tatsächlich ein Kritikpunkt, der am Anfang dieser Diskussion hochkam, den sie auch nachgebessert haben. Und zwar war es so, dass die Chips am Anfang, also den ersten Projekt dazu, tatsächlich eine konstante Chip-ID ausgeliefert haben, sobald man da Strom angelegt hat. Das heißt also, der Chip hatte halt eine eineindeutige Identifikationsnummer. Und dann fiel nicht nur den Amerikanern, sondern auch allen anderen Leuten auf, dass es eine ziemlich blöde Idee ist, weil man damit a. natürlich feststellen kann, welcher Nationalität jemand angehört, was dann halt natürlich sofort zu schönen Terroristen können jetzt Amerikaner ratlos jagen, Schlagzeilen in Amerika führte. Und b. könnte man sich natürlich solche Szenarien vorstellen, wie zum Beispiel eine Bombe im Türrahmen, die halt nur auf einen bestimmten Reisepass wartet. Dementsprechend wurden jetzt halt zumindest in Deutschland spezifiziert und ich denke in Amerika würde es auch passieren, dass der Reisepass, wenn er Strom bekommt, über die Funktionstelle jedes Mal eine zufällige ID ausliefert, die nur so lange gültig ist, wie er halt Strom über diese Funktionstelle bekommt. Und in die, zumindest nachdem, was wir bisher wissen, ist es nicht möglich ohne Advanced Authentication in die schreibbaren Bereiche des Reisepasses reinzuschreiben. Das heißt, da ein Cookie im Kaufhaus zu setzen ist halt ein bisschen schwierig. Ob man ein Cookie an der Grenze setzen kann, entzieht sich halt unser Kenntnis.
Wäre ja nicht unbedingt notwendig, ein Cookie zu setzen. Also nur in einem Band von Symbolen oder von Schrift, um zu sagen, ach, das ist ja der, der letzte Woche schon das heftige X-User gekauft hat.
Ja, also nach bisherigen Standerkenntnissen ist das ausgeschlossen durch die Design des Chips.
Aber Sie können es natürlich zentral einfach in der Datenbank speichern. Das heißt, Sie lesen da ein Chip ein, wie Sie es jetzt mit der Kundenkarte auch machen und haben da einfach eine zentrale Datenbank.
Das ist ja viel einfacher. Also im Koffers kann Sie halt irgendwie nicht unbemerkt ein Chip auslesen, sondern...
Unbemerkt nicht, aber eine Kundenkarte muss ja auch den in die Hand geben.
Genau.
Aber der ausweist doch nicht. Ja, aber Sie drücken einfach eine Kundenkarte mit RFID in die Hand und dann ist das viel einfacher.
Ja, okay, aber mit dem Reise passt da nichts mehr zu tun.
Nee, das ist richtig.
Und noch eine zweite Frage, das kommt wahrscheinlich noch, wie kann man diese RFID-Auslesemöglichkeit blocken? Also sowas wie Faraday-Shark-Häfig, dass man das in seinen Ausweis in einen schächtlichen...
Also wir arbeiten dann gerade noch an Experimenten, das hängt am Ende davon ab, welchen Reader sie an der Grenze benutzen, teils mit welcher Feldstärke der Chip ausgelesen wird. Also bei den Test-Readern, mit denen wir gestern experimentiert haben, reicht halt ein Stück Alufolie. Das muss noch nicht mehr ringsrum sein, sondern reicht, wenn das halt in der Nähe war, und so groß auch wieder passbar. Es könnte sein, dass man da noch etwas stärkere Abschirmungsmethoden machen muss, wenn die Reader halt mit höherer Feldstärke lesen.
Aber der Trick dabei ist, dass du verhinderst, dass der Reader, der das Lesegerät versorgt, über ein elektromagnetisches Feld, den Chip mit Strom, er hat ja keine eigene Batterie. Und die Idee ist, dass du diese Antenne quasi so verfälscht oder so abdeckst, dass sich da kein Feld aufbauen kann. Also der Reader aus der Antenne keine Energie mehr ziehen kann. Wenn du das verhinderst, dann bist du da ganz gut dran.
Also das einfachste wirklich, mehrere Lagen Alufolie rumwickeln, das sollte helfen.
Also diese RSA, die hatten doch mal auf, das war glaube ich im Rahmen von einer Messe, ich glaube CeBIT war das, 2004, ein Beutelchen ausgegeben. Da war ein Medikament drin mit einem RFID-Chip und das sollte irgendwie Störfrequenzen, so ein RFID-Blocker war das, aussenden. War das jetzt nur ein Gag oder?
Das war ein Gag, da gibt es auch so eine Geschichte. Was sie gemacht haben, ist einfach nur einen anderen Tag, der sozusagen, ich glaube, sie haben eine Software. Google mal danach, da gibt es eine Geschichte, es haben Leute sich angeguckt und das, was sie zumindest auf der Messe gezeigt haben, war nicht das, was sie behauptet haben.
Also was man natürlich noch machen kann, ist mehrere RFID-Tags noch zusätzlich ins Formulier zu stecken und irgendwie ab einer gewissen Anzahl, so 10, 15 Stück, kriegen die Leser halt einfach Probleme mit der Antikollision und das sollte einem Auslesen auch wirkungsvoll verändern.
Aber Alufolie oder so ein kleines Metall, das ist einfach.
Dann gibt es noch Fragen über Fragen. Gibt es noch eine maximale Anzahl, die ein Reader verarbeiten kann an RFIDs?
Gleichzeitig oder? Also es gab ursprünglich den Plan, auch Sichtvermerk, also sprich Visa in den Pass einzubauen, die auch über Chips verfügen. Das heißt, wenn du irgendwie nach, weiß nicht, nach Vietnam oder nach China gehst, die kleben dir halt ein Visum rein und da ist auch ein RFID-Chip drinne. Sie haben dann mal festgestellt, dass diese sogenannte Kollisionserkennung, das heißt also mehrere Chips gleichzeitig in einem Feld, eben so nicht so richtig toll funktioniert. Das ist jetzt kein Garant dafür, dass es auch in Zukunft nicht so richtig toll funktionieren wird, aber sie sind von der Idee abgekommen und werden jetzt tendenziell wahrscheinlich dazu übergehen, die Sachen auch zentral auf einem Chip zu speichern. Das heißt also, wie die Papierseiten hinten drin, da Sachen reingesteckt oder reingeklemmt werden, reingeklebt werden, werden dann möglicherweise auch noch Sachen in einem extra Visumsbereich dann auf dem Chip gespeichert.
Wie ist denn so der Stand der Vorarbeit? Also arbeitet irgendwer schon daran, weiß ich nicht, ich hab grad so ein Bild vom Kopf wie vom Furburt diese Privacy Card, dass ich irgendwann eine Kreditkarte vom Furburt für 5 Euro mir kaufe, wo 180 RFID-Text drin sind, und ich mir die einfach nur noch ins Portemonnaie stecke und damit mehr oder minder gesichert bin. Gibt's da irgendwelche, bastelt irgendwer schon irgendwas?
Das soll eigentlich kein großes Problem sein, aber irgendwie, also es gibt vom Furburt auch so ein Zigaretten-Etui, wo du deine Karten reinstecken kannst, wie Alufolie rumwickeln, bloß ein bisschen schöner. Das heißt, du musst es halt nicht wirklich stören, sondern am besten ist einfach irgendwie abschirmen in eine Alufolie oder halt in so ein Etui reinstecken und damit bist du halt sicher.
Ich mach ne Portemonnaie-Fabrik auf. Martin, fertig oder geht's weiter? Danke für deinen Anruf. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer dieser Sendung und diese Sendung, die heißt Chaosradio und die hört ihr im Radio. So heißt das Radio. Wie gesagt, Chaosradio. Chaosradio 196, der elektronische Reisepass. Das Thema am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Heißt die Sendung, in deren Rahmen das Chaosradio stattfindet. Wie erreicht man uns, Frank?
Schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und vielleicht noch mal ein Hinweis in eigener Sache. Es gibt morgen bei der Humanistischen Union in Berlin ein sogenanntes VESPA, wir machen einen Biometrie-VESPA. Das ist also eine Veranstaltung, weiß nicht, wer es bei uns vielleicht kennt. Das ist der sogenannte Datengarten. Es ist also eine offene Veranstaltung, wo jeder eingeladen ist zu kommen. Da wird es um das Thema gehen. Biometrisch vermessen leben wir so sicherer. Und das beginnt um, muss ich nachschauen, beginnt um 19 Uhr und ist im Haus der Demokratie und Menschenrechte in der Greifswalder Straße 4. Mal schauen, vielleicht kriegen wir das nachher noch auf die Webseite rauf bei uns. Aber zur Not, wenn ihr das jetzt nicht mitbekommen habt, schreibt eine Mail an chaosradioaccc.de, denn schicke ich euch es nochmal.
Und möglicherweise habt ihr ja auch noch die eine oder andere Frage zum Thema der elektronische Reisepass. Ab 1. November wird es einen Reisepass geben, der über einen Chip verfügt. In diesem Chip sind dann biometrische Daten gespeichert, unter anderem das Gesicht und später dann auch irgendwann mal der Fingerabdruck 0331 77 97 110. Ja Ihr, den Blumen auf Fritz, am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, da gibt es außer im Dezember immer das Chaos Radio hier mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Im Studio sind Frank, Frank und Starbuck. Die Knöpfe drücke ich. Ich heiße Holger Klein und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 euch zu äußern zu unserem Thema. Und das Thema ist der elektronische Reisepass. Ab dem 1. November wird in Deutschland weltweit einmalig, wie nennt man das, Premiere sozusagen, Weltpremiere, ein Reisepass eingeführt, in dem auch biometrische Daten vermerkt sind. Das finden wir nicht wirklich gut, weil auch nicht wirklich darüber diskutiert wurde vom Souverän, der ja immerhin die Politiker legitimiert, die die Einführung dieses Passes vorangetrieben haben. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. 033 177 91 110 angerufen hat der Holger aus Berlin.
Holger, mach dein Radio aus. Mach ich. Hallo.
So, du bist dran.
Ja, also ich wollte sagen, dass ich grundsätzlich schon in eurer Meinung bin, aber doch finde, dass das so eine, wie soll ich das nennen, so eine reflexive Ablehnungshaltung ist, die ich von mir selbst auch oft kenne und ich aber nicht den Eindruck hab, dass ihr wirklich beispielsweise daran interessiert seid, an der Diskussion, wie man denn tatsächlich was gegen den Terror tun könnte. Und es gibt nun mal Terror, der auch ein anderer Terror ist, als jetzt beispielsweise in den 70er Jahren bei der RAF, wo ich das auch wirklich als Hysterie bezeichnen würde. Aber wenn ihr schon die Frage stellt, glaubt ihr, dass so die biometrischen Daten uns für den bösen Terroristen schützen, dann höre ich ja schon aus der Frage heraus.
Okay, dann stelle ich mal eine journalistisch saubere, neutrale Frage. Auf welche Weise glaubst du, dass ein biometrischer Pass uns vor terroristischen Anschlägen schützen wird?
Also ich kann zum Beispiel darauf hinweisen, dass die Leute in Madrid schon geschnappt wurden, weil zum Beispiel die Handy abgehört wurden.
Nein, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Ich rede hier nicht von Fahndung, von Aufklärung nach dem Verbrechen, sondern von Schutz davor. Mir wird gesagt, dass dieser Pass mich davor schützt, dass er mich sicherer macht. Nicht, dass es hinterher eine bessere Aufklärungsquote gibt.
Das halte ich so unmittelbar natürlich auch für Quatsch. Aber man kann natürlich sagen, je mehr Repression da ist, ob man das jetzt gut will oder nicht, ich finde es auch natürlich nicht durchweg gut, aber je schwerer einem gemacht wird irgendwie unerkannt sich zu bewegen, desto schwerer ist es natürlich auch, Terror zu verüben. Also beispielsweise in 70er Jahren bei der RAF, wo es das alles erstmal noch nicht gab, da konnte man einfach mal so eine Bank überfallen und das ist heute zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht mehr möglich, weil eben alle möglichen Mittel eben gefunden wurden.
Warum werden noch so viele Banken überfallen? Warum werden dann noch so viele Banken überfallen derzeit?
Also es werden bestimmt nicht so unprofessionell und mal eben Banken überfallen.
Niemand ist dagegen, effiziente Sicherheitsmaßnahmen einzuführen, die irgendeiner Art von realistischer Erhöhung des Sicherheitsniveaus ohne massiver Beeinträchtigung der bürgerlichen Freiheiten bieten. Also bei den Banken ist es zum Beispiel so, dass der wesentliche Punkt, warum man Banken heutzutage nicht mehr überfallen kann oder nicht mehr gut überfallen kann, ist, dass wir da Saves mit Zeitverzögerungen haben. Was eine sehr einfache Technologie ist, die niemanden irgendwie stört, die aber das Überfallen einer Bank mit hoher Beute nahezu unmöglich macht. Ähnliche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ist zum Beispiel mal ordentliche dicke Türen in die Flugzeuge einbauen. Das sind Maßnahmen, wo man sagen kann, okay, die sind einfach, die bringen tatsächlich Sinn, die verhindern möglicherweise sogar Terrorismus und es gibt niemanden, der da irgendwie tatsächlich großartig drunter leidet. Da ist niemand dagegen. Das finde ich sehr sinnvoll. Irgendwie wir sind sicherlich die Letzten, die sagen, okay, irgendwie wir wollen lieber weniger Sicherheit haben. Aber ich sage mal, niemand konnte bisher erfolgreich zeigen, dass sowas wie die Einführung von Biometrie in Reisepässen die Sache tatsächlich sicherer macht. Also ich bin persönlich der Meinung, das macht die Sache unsicherer, weil am Ende der Grenzbeamte sich auf diesen Chip verlassen wird, der im Zweifel nicht getestet, nicht ausgereift und nicht erprobt ist. Und deswegen wundere ich mich immer wieder, dass so Maßnahmen, die halt als Erhöhung der Sicherheit verkauft werden, bei näherer Betrachtung, wenn man sich noch ein bisschen beschäftigt, sich eigentlich als totaler Bullshit daraus stellt und am Ende dazu führen, dass die Sachen unsicherer werden. Ich bin gerade aus London wiedergekommen und durch die erhöhten Sicherheitskontrollen ist es da so in London Stanced It, dass zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt ungefähr 500 Leute auf engstem Raum vor der Sicherheitskontrolle zusammengeballt stehen. So und selbiges Spiel auf den Bahnhöfen in London. Die Leute werden nicht mehr auf die Bahnsteige gelassen, sondern werden davon weggehalten bei den Computer Trains und stehen halt alle in der Vorhelle. In der Vorhelle auf der Liverpool Street Station stehen zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt abends 5 bis 600 Leute auf engstem Raum. So und das alles wegen der sogenannten Sicherheit. Vorher haben sich die Leute verteilt, da gab es nicht Konzentrationen. Das ist halt genau der Kritikpunkt, da wird halt, um Aktionismus zu zeigen, Profit zu machen, was auch immer, wird irgendetwas als Sicherheitsmaßnahmen verkauft, dass aber am Ende keine Sicherheit macht. Und das ist der eigentlich Kritikpunkt, den wir haben.
Ja, aber das Beispiel ist doch super, was du gerade gebracht hast. Ich meine, diese Staus entstehen natürlich, weil die Taschen einfach ein bisschen genauer kontrolliert werden. Und das ist ja nach so Anschlägen nur allzu verständlich. Also, dass das natürlich auch nervig ist für die Leute und sicherlich auch, also glaube ich, ich habe eure Meinung, dass das auch missbraucht ist und so. Das sehe ich schon. Aber ich habe also ich habe das Gefühl, dass es euch wichtiger ist, das zu kritisieren, als wirklich. Also, ihr habt nicht einmal bisher die Frage gestellt, was kann man denn tatsächlich gegen den Terror machen oder so? Wenn ihr in der Brücke redet, dann merke ich, dass ihr das auch verharmlost, dass euch das letztendlich scheißegal ist.
Das ist, stopp mal Holger, das ist erstens ist es nicht das Thema der Sendung, die Frage, was kann man denn tun, sondern das Thema der Sendung ist, was ist denn dieser elektronische Reisepass für ein Ding? Und das ist offensichtlich ein Ding, das nicht so funktioniert, wie uns gesagt wird, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, aber wieso, wie soll man das? Es wurde doch bisher noch gar nicht erprobt, es klag aber im Vorhinein nicht belegen, dass damit Terrorismus sichtbar verhindert wird. Aber was soll man denn, stell mal vor du bist Innenminister, was willst du denn machen?
Also du musst doch irgendwie...
Oh, da würden mir aber eine ganze Menge Sachen einfallen. Also ich meine, zum Beispiel würde ich mal dafür sorgen, dass die Leute, die irgendwie mit den Maschinenpistolen vor den öffentlichen Gebäuden rumstehen, erst mal ordentliche Schießausbildung bekommen, weil im Moment habe ich mir da eher Sorgen, wenn da irgendwas passiert, wenn da so ein 55-Jähriger, der dir irgendwie zum letzten Mal vor zwei Jahren auf dem Schießstand war, plötzlich mit seiner MP rumfruchtelt, dass der Kollateralschaden wesentlich höher ist. Zum anderen würde ich einfach mal hingehen und überlegen, welche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen bringen tatsächlich Effizienzsicherheit. Solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel Vorschreiben, dass dickere Türen in Flugzeuge eingebaut werden. Es hat zweieinhalb Jahre gedauert, bis sich irgendjemand mal dazu bequemt hat. Stattdessen diskutieren die Leute darüber, ob man Atomkraftwerke von den Landkarten streichen soll oder da GSM-Gemma einbaut. Das ist totaler... Oder Nebelmaschinen. Oder Nebelmaschinen. Das ist wirklich großartig. Jeder, der mal in einem Privatflugzeug gesessen hat, wird wissen, dass es irgendwie vollkommen sinnlos ist. Das Einzige, was so ein Land effektiv vor Terrorismus schützen kann, ist eine vernünftige Außenpolitik. Seien wir uns doch da mal einig. Und der Grund, warum irgendwie Anschläge in Großbritannien, in Madrid stattfinden, ist eigentlich offensichtlich und klar. Ich sage nicht, dass man sich jetzt dem irgendwie vollständig unterwerfen muss, aber man kann halt auch einfach eine sensible Außenpolitik betreiben. Und letzten Endes ist es so, Strukturen wie Großstädte sind vor Anschlägen nicht zu schützen. Und wenn man jetzt versucht, seine Bevölkerung komplett unter Kontrolle zu halten, dann möchte man das bitte auch als offizielle Ziel deklarieren. Wenn halt das Ziel ist, dass diese Gesellschaft sich zu einem Polizeistadt entwickelt, in dem jeder permanent getrackt werden kann, dann möchte es bitte auch einen gesellschaftlichen Konsens darüber geben, dass die Leute das wirklich wollen und nicht irgendwie entschieden von so ein paar Politikern, die nicht mal demokratisch gewählt sind, Stichwort EU-Ministerrat, wo halt einfach keine Legitimation da ist, die irgendwie zu rechtfertigen ist, die dann plötzlich beschließen, wir müssen jetzt mal alle von allen die Fingerabdrücke abnehmen. Da gibt es keine Legitimation eigentlich dafür. Und dann uns hinterher erzählen wollen, dass es zu mehr Sicherheit führt, das finde ich einfach nur verlogen. Also dann kann ich den Leuten auch schlicht nicht mehr glauben, wenn sie mir versuchen.
Aber was ist denn daran so abwegig, wenn man jetzt mal sich überlegt, dass es irgendein Anschlag passiert, und man hat nun mal von jedem die Fingerabdrücke, dann ist doch für mich ist das schon...
Dann ist der Anschlag schon passiert.
Du kannst den Anschlag auch wunderbar verhindern, indem du einfach die gesamte Bevölkerung ins Gefängnis steckst.
Lass uns noch einen Satz mal zu Ende reden, bevor ihr im Rhein greift.
Quatsch, aber zumindest hat man doch dann als Politiker den Anspruch, den Anschlag aufzuklären. Also klar ist der dann schon passiert. Also wenn man würde, dass man das nicht damit verhindern kann, das ist ja irgendwie das behauptet, glaube ich, auch niemand. Ja, aber das ist doch jetzt...
Das ist genau der Punkt.
Aber das stimmt aber nicht. Das ist ja das, was ich sage, dass je mehr Repression da ist, wie gesagt, ohne frei von Wertung, desto schwerer hat es einen Terrorist. Das ist ein Fakt. Und der wird es auch schwerer haben, wenn er nicht so ohne Weiteres hin und her reisen kann und all diese Sachen. Und jetzt sind wir zu sagen, da sind ziehen die Gummihandschuhe an oder wenn er sich in die Luft sprengt, dann will er sich in die Luft sprengen, dann kann er das auch machen. Klar kann er das auch machen. Aber so kannst du als Politiker ja nicht argumentieren.
Du musst ja irgendwie... Aber Holger, wie viel Repression ist denn dann angemessen?
Das ist ja eine ganz andere Frage. Aber das Ding ist einfach... Also was mich einfach nervt, das kenn ich in meinem Freundeskreis und Bekanntenkreis ja auch, dass die Leute einfach... Ja, das war erst mal so ein Flex da, erst mal lehne ich alles ab, weil es war erst mal sowieso alles nur Hintergedanke und das alles Scheiße und sie wollen mich überwachen und so weiter. Aber ich mein, also ich weiß nicht, wenn ich am Flughafen... Mich nervt das manchmal auch und neulich war es so, da musste ich irgendwie durch die Sperre, dann musste ich nochmal kontrolliert werden und dann musste ich nochmal durch und nochmal meine Schuhe ausziehen. Und da habe ich auch gesagt, mein Gott, ihre Kolleginnen gingen doch die ganze Zeit mit mir mit, sie haben doch gesehen, dass ich nicht in die Schuhe gestopft hab. Und da hat er gesagt, das macht ihm auch keinen Spaß, aber es beschweren sich die Leute, wenn sie sehen, dass da einer durchgeht, der vorher noch, also weil sie es nicht gesehen haben, dass er vorher schon mal durchgegangen ist und sie fühlen sich einfach unsicher im Flugzeug und deswegen muss das gemacht werden. Und da muss ich sagen, mein Gott, da hab ich Verständnis für mein, dann zieh ich halt nochmal meine Schuhe aus. Also ich freu mich auch, wenn ich genau sehe, dass die Leute verprügelt werden.
Willst du dann wirklich deine Fingerabbrücke abgeben, nur damit ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung beruhigt ist?
Also dann sag mir mal ganz konkret, was ist daran so unendlich dramatisch, wenn ich meine Fingerabbrücke abgebe?
Das Problem ist, das ist ein weiterer Schritt zu einem Überwachungsstaat.
Das ist aber eine allgemeine Flotte. Sag es mir mal ganz konkret. Also ich bin überhaupt nicht so einer, der sagt, wer nichts getan hat, der hat auch nichts zu befürchten. Das ist naiv, das ist Quatsch. Aber wenn ich jetzt mal davon ausgehe, ich hab einen Ausweis, da ist mein Foto drin, den Ausweis, den habe ich, um damit identifiziert zu werden. Und mit dem Fingerabdruck, da kann ich nur noch viel exakter identifiziert werden. Und wenn ich mit dem ersten einverstanden bin, dann müsste ich doch mit dem zweiten rein theoretisch auch einverstanden sein.
Deine Annahme gründet sich darauf, dass du davon ausgehst, dass die Demokratie in Deutschland auf die nächsten 50 Jahre stabil ist, dass wir nie wieder eine Situation haben werden, dass der Staat nicht in der Lage ist, sagen wir mal die Rechte seiner Bürger hinreichend zu würdigen, dass er sich nicht in totalitäre Abgründe begibt. Und diese Annahme habe ich nicht, die kann ich auch nicht teilen. Und vorhin mein Beispiel, die DDR waren totalitärer Überwachungsstaat, zumindest in weiten Teilen, aber nicht mal die DDR hat es sich getraut, alle ihre Leute Fingerabdruck zu erfassen. Was ich sehe, ist, dass ein Teil der Politiker in Europa darauf hinsteuert zu sagen, okay, die Lage wird immer beschissener, wir haben irgendwie eine Klimakatastrophe, wir haben irgendwie das Problem, dass wir ein hohes Wohlstandsgefälle haben. Wir sehen, dass wir in den nächsten 10 bis 15 Jahren viel massivere Pressionen ausüben müssen, um den Status quo noch aufrechterhalten zu können. Und was wir gerade sehen, sind einfach die Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen genau dafür. Da wird der Terrorismus, der so schlimmer ist, tatsächlich, was irgendwie die Anzahl von Menschen leben, die dabei drauf geht, nicht mal mit den Verkehrsunfällen zu vergleichen ist, wenn man es mal zynisch betrachtet. Der wird halt einfach missbraucht, um den Staat in einer Art und Weise umzubauen, die uns darauf vorbereitet zu sagen, okay, es heißt zwar noch Demokratie, aber am Ende werden wir regiert von ein paar Leuten, die halt sagen, okay, du musst jetzt alle ganz sicher sein. Und das finde ich einfach keine Tendenz, die irgendwie auch nur im Ansatz unterstützenswert ist. Wenn sie belegen können, dass ihre Maßnahmen irgendwas bringen, dann sollen sie es bitte machen. Aber sie geben sich nicht mal die Mühe, zu versuchen zu belegen, dass ihre Maßnahmen...
Das kann man ja erst belegen, wenn man es mal eingeführt hat. Ich meine, ich geb dir schon bis zum gewissen Grad recht. Da ist natürlich was dran. Aber jetzt einfach mal angenommen, unterstelle mir mal irgendeinen Politiker, er will wirklich den Terrorismus verhindern. Der hat doch im Grunde jetzt, wenn Leute das argumentieren, wie ihr, gar keine Möglichkeit, irgendwas zu machen, weil bei allem gleich gesagt wird, ach, das ist Überwachung.
Er hat ja auch, Holger, er hat doch sowieso keine Möglichkeit. Wenn ich jetzt...
Was ist das für ein Argument?
Nein, was ist das Argument des Politikers, bitte schön, für eines, der mir versucht weiß zu machen, er wäre in der Lage, einen Anschlag zu verhindern. Wenn irgendjemand einen Anschlag verüben will, dann wird er das tun, egal wie hoch die Repression ist. Es sei denn, du machst einen totalitären Überwachungsstaat draus und verfolgst wirklich jeden minutiös jederzeit. Dann kannst du vielleicht sehen, dass ein, wie auch immer geartetes, auffälliges Verhalten dazu führt, dass dieser jemand vorher aus dem Verkehr gezogen wird. Und selbst dann ist die Sicherheit immer noch nicht gegeben, die da eingefordert wird. Und was da noch darüber hinausgeht, Holger, ist, in dem Moment, wo ein Fingerabdruck in einem Pass oder überhaupt ein abgegebener Fingerabdruck einen Fahndungserfolg zeigen kann, kann nur passieren, wenn alle Fingerabdrücke zentral gespeichert sind. So, und die Kontrolle darüber, wer Zugriff auf diese zentrale Fingerabdruckdatei hat, die ist nicht gegeben. Wer soll das auf welche Weise kontrollieren?
Das ist natürlich ein Argument, da stimme ich euch vollkommen zu. Und das ist natürlich auch kritikwürdig.
Und dann geht's ja noch weiter. In dem Moment, wo ich auf eine zentrale Fingerabdruckdatei Zugriff habe, kann ich jederzeit kontrollieren, wo du dich aufgehalten hast. Was du da gemacht hast, was du angefasst hast, was du vielleicht aus dem Regal genommen hast, um es dir anzugucken und es dann doch nicht gekauft hast und hinterher mir überlegen, was kann ich tun, damit er mir dieses Produkt doch abkauft. Also da sind unendliche Szenarien lenkbar.
Und der Terrorist kann halt weiterhin seine Fingerabdrücke verstecken und irgendwie trotzdem seine Anschläge durchführen.
Ich glaube auch ein wesentlicher Punkt ist, was wir jetzt sehen, es ist halt wirklich nur immer der erste Schritt. Und in den USA ist jetzt gerade das Gesetz vorgelegt worden, dass das FBI die Rechte des Rechts möchte jeden verdächtigen, wohl gemerkt jeden verdächtigen, den sie festnehmen eine DNA-Probe abzunehmen und diese für immer zu speichern, ohne dass derjenige ein Lösungsrecht hätte. Selbst wenn er hinterher unschuldig als unschuldig erkannt wird und die Ermittlungen eingestellt werden, wird trotzdem seine DNA-Probe weiter gespeichert. Und ich denke, das wird nicht lange dauern, bis wir sowas ähnlich in Europa auch haben. Und der Schritt dann bis zur kompletten Erfassung der DNA-Spuren, der Gesamtbevölkerung ist dann nicht besonders weit. Es gibt schon Politiker in Holland, die genau sowas fordern, dass schon bei der Geburt jedem eine DNA-Probe abgenommen wird, um hin und später identifizieren zu können. Und wenn ich sowas höre, dann kann ich nur sagen, wenn sie das durchziehen, dann werden sie am Ende vermutlich einfach mehr Terrorismus haben, weil die Leute irgendwann nicht nur so voll von sowas haben. Und insofern kann ich nicht nachvollziehen, dass es irgendetwas zur Sicherheit beiträgt.
Ja, aber es gab zum Beispiel auch so ein Beispiel von so einem Kinderschänder, wo so ein genetischer Abdruck von allen Männern in der Region gemacht wurde. Und dann wurde er dadurch sehr schnell gefasst, so als ein Beispiel.
Und deswegen möchtest du, dass der Staat das Recht hat, jeden Einzelnen darauf zu untersuchen, wie sie dafür abzuhalten können?
Nein, das habe ich ja die ganze Zeit betont, als ich es nicht möchte. Aber dieses konsequente Ablehen von allem, was auch nur angedacht wird, und immer gleich als Hinweis darauf zu deuten, dass es einen Schritt weiter in die totale Überwachung ist, das ist mir halt, wie gesagt, so sehr ich teilweise auch eurer Meinung bin, aber das ist mir teilweise so ein bisschen zu einfach. Und ich merke, dass man da einfach, ja, dass man das auch so verharmlost, dass man so, wenn man so einfach dahin sagt, ach Terrorismus kann man sowieso nicht verhindern. Also das ist irgendwie...
Ja, aber kann man doch auch nicht. Dann sag mir, wie du ihn verhinderst.
Natürlich, also was heißt kann man doch auch nicht.
Ja, auf welche Weise willst du Terrorismus verhindern? Dann vielleicht hast du ein Patentrezept, von dem wir alle nicht wissen. Aber es ist meines Erachtens nicht möglich. Es wird immer eine hinreichende Menge Leute geben, die sich Waffen besorgen, die sich Sprengstoff besorgen und damit irgendwelche anderen Leute in die Luft jagen oder erschießen, weil sie da gerade Bock drauf haben oder um irgendein politisches Ziel zu verfolgen. Und wie hinderst du die daran, das zu tun?
Ja, indem man ihnen diese Sachen, die sie brauchen, einfach schwerer macht. Also es ist bestimmt schwerer, was weiß ich, auf den Kudam einen Sprengstoffanschlag zu machen als im Irak, beispielsweise.
Das heißt du willst eine Zutrenskontrolle für den Kudam einführen, oder?
Ne, das ist jetzt wieder Polemik, das sag ich ja nicht. Aber das ist doch Quatsch zu sagen, man kann nichts dagegen tun. Man kann, wenn man will, sehr viel dagegen tun.
Na dann sag doch mal ein konkretes Beispiel, was man dagegen tun kann.
Na ja, da gibt es doch tausend Beispiele.
Na dann sag doch mal bitte ein konkretes Beispiel.
Ich hab mir, also zum Beispiel, wenn man, was weiß ich, wenn man irgendwo, ja was weiß ich, also ich, wie gesagt, ich bin wirklich nicht dafür, aber wenn man zum Beispiel U-Bahnhöfe Video überwacht, dann sieht man vielleicht, wie jemand eine Bombe da abdepponiert.
Und dann ist er explodiert und alles ist vorbei.
Vielleicht hat man es auch vorher schon festgestellt, was weiß ich, vielleicht kann man es dadurch leuchten und sieht, dass es tickt und kann sie, ich hab ja keine Ahnung, aber kann sie entschärfen oder so und dann ist er eben nicht explodiert.
Also die Geschichte mit der Videoüberwachung...
Ich bin um Gottes Willen nicht für Videoüberwachung.
Nein, ich finde die interessant, weil das ist ein Beispiel, was dich auch mal wieder zielspält. Ich finde, weil natürlich ist es schon so, dass wenn man nach London sagen kann, okay Videoüberwachung bricht ja immerhin, wenn man hinterher sehen kann, wer es war. Nun gab es letzte Woche diese Geschichte von dem Reuters Reporter, der in London festgenommen wurde und zwar durchaus etwas roh und festgehalten wurde und sich eine Anzeige eingehandelt hat und so weiter und so fort. Einfach aus dem Grund, weil er sich in der Videoüberwachung offensichtlich irgendwie verdächtig benommen hat. Also er hat auf sein Telefon geguckt und hinter ihm wurde gesagt, er hätte den Polizisten, die am U-Bahneingang standen, nicht in die Augen geguckt. Er hatte auch noch einen Rucksack und hat irgendwie irgendwas auf seinem Laptop, hat er Wikipedia gelesen oder so. Und das war halt hinreichend verdächtig. Entschuldige bitte, ich meine, das ist genau das, was ich irgendwie jeden Tag mache, wenn ich irgendwie U-Bahn fahre in Berlin.
Ja, und du hast doch noch einen Bad.
Ja, und ich hab noch einen Bad, weißt du.
Da ich nach London gefahren bin, letzte Woche, die vorletzte Woche, da habe ich mit Absicht meinen Rucksack nicht mitgenommen, sondern mir extra eine Umhängetasche geborgt.
So einfach, weil ich einfach Schiss hatte.
Und zwar vor der Polizei.
Ja, aber das ist ja kein Argument gegen die Überwachung, sondern gegen den Mist oder die schlampige Art.
Der ist aber inhärent. Du kannst nichts dagegen tun. Guck dir an. Ja, Moment, aber Überwachung wird immer von Menschen durchgeführt. Überwachung wird immer von Menschen ausgewertet. Und diese Menschen sind per Definition die unterbezahltesten und dümmsten Mitarbeiter, die du auf diesem Planeten finden kannst. Weil diesen Job will genau niemand tun. Der kommt genauer nach Straßenkehrer. Na, was es in der Konsequenz heißt, dass es nicht funktioniert, weil diese Leute nicht in der Lage sind, irgendwie eine sinnvolle Auswertung zu machen.
Also ich bin mir sicher, wenn es zum Beispiel, wenn ich ein Flugzeug besteigen muss, ich durch einen Metalldetektor, wenn ich Metall bei mir hab, piept und dann darf ich nicht rein. Wenn es diesen Metalldetektor nicht gäbe, bin ich mir sicher, würden mehr Flugzeuge entführt werden.
Da spricht doch nichts dagegen.
Ja, aber das ist nur ein Argument, dass man kann was dagegen machen.
Ich bin am Montag von Oslo nach Berlin geflogen, bin durch den Metalldetektor gegangen, bin durchleuchtet worden, bin abgetastet worden, bin danach in den Duty-Free-Shop gegangen und hab mir im Duty-Free-Shop eine Schere gekauft.
Ja, aber das ist doch eher ein Argument, da unterstützt er meine Argumentation. Da sagst du ja, dass die Überwachung noch nicht gut genug ist nach dieser Logik.
Nein, ein Metalldetektor ist keine Überwachung. Was steht da? Ein Metalldetektor ist eine sensible, einfache Sicherheitsmaßnahme. Dass hinterher Holger sich noch irgendwie eine Schere in Duty-Free-Shop gekauft hat, ist halt einfach nur Bescheuheit. Aber ein Metalldetektor, das kann jeder einsehen. Weißt du, das ist irgendwie kein großes Problem. Was aber wieder das Problem ist, ist die Durchführung dieser Sicherheitsmaßnahmen. In London Stance war es so, dass es genau zwei Metalldetektoren gab für ungefähr fünfzehn gleichzeitig abfliegende Flugzeuge. Nebenan waren acht Stück unbesetzt. Und das ist genau das Problem. Wenn man effizient Sicherheit haben will, dann muss man die intelligent durchführen. Dann muss man daran denken, dass man genug Leute da hat, daran denken, dass man genug Maschinen da hat. Dann muss man einfach überlegen, was macht die Sache wirklich sicherer und nicht, wie kriege ich möglichst viel Daten. Und was ich momentan sehe, ist, dass unsere Sicherheitspolitik darauf ausgerichtet ist, wie baut man einen möglichst unauffälligen Überwachungsstaat.
Ja, da ist sicher was dran. Und dennoch denke ich auch, dass durch eine gewisse Datensammlung man schon Erkenntnisse gewinnen kann, die auch vorbeugen, wirken können. Aber auch wenn es natürlich...
Das sind ganz schön viele Konjunktive, die du da anführst.
Ja, aber es wird bei euch ja nicht anders.
Wir haben uns die Technik soweit auseinandergenommen, um zu wissen, dass hier einfach genau nicht funktioniert. Das ist irgendwie Fakten und irgendwie... Du hast bis jetzt immer noch kein Beispiel, wie ein biometrischer Reisepass.
Also von der Technik hab ich mit Sicherheit, ich hab mich jetzt auch nicht so intensiv damit beschäftigt, da will ich euch jetzt auch einfach mal so glauben, mir ging es auch mehr so um dieses Allgemeine, ob man jetzt generell erstmal alles grundlegend in Frage stellt und verteufelt oder ob man auch mal einfach einen guten Willen hier und da unterstellt.
Das waren jetzt zwei Teile. Man sollte, finde ich, grundsätzlich alles in Frage stellen. Und wenn es wert ist, zu verteufeln, auch verteufeln, aber erstmal in Frage stellen.
Das auf jeden Fall, aber dann, wenn man feststellt, es gibt eigentlich dann doch keinen Grund, nur so massiv in Frage zu stellen, dann halt auch wieder davon wegkommen. Und das ist genau das Problem.
Aber genau das Gegenteil hat der CCC festgestellt. Genau.
Also es geht einfach, wir haben halt irgendwie die Technik untersucht und wir haben festgestellt, dass es halt genau keinen Sinn macht. Und deswegen bleiben wir halt natürlich auf unseren Argumenten irgendwie, verharrn wir darauf, weil es halt einfach technisch irgendwie wir gesehen haben, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Also um nochmal zum Beispiel dieses Biometrie Beispiel zurückzukommen. Es ist ja so, dass diese Biop-2-Studie, die ich vorhin schon mal erwähnt hatte, die hat halt festgestellt, dass diese Biometrie nicht mehr funktioniert. Also dass sie a. eine relativ hohe Rate und bzw. eine relativ hohe Möglichkeit hat, dass Leute einfach so durchkommen, weil sie halt ähnliche biometrische Merkmale haben, gerade bei der Gesichtserkennung. Und dass sie b. dazu führt, dass eine Menge Leute, die ganz legal durchgehen könnten, sollten schlicht nicht durchgehen können. Außerdem gibt es noch eine ganze Menge Leute, die schlicht nicht genügend biometrische Merkmale haben, als dass sie sinnvoll ausgewertet werden können. Man rechnet damit, dass aber 2% der Bevölkerung keinen verwertbaren Fingerabdruck haben, weil sie halt manueller Tätigkeit nachgehen, weil die Fingerabdrücke abgeschliffen werden. Das führt halt alles dazu, dass halt eine große Menge Leute massiv in ihren Bürgerrechten beeinträchtigt wird, weil diese Leute werden halt immer Stress haben. Jedes einzelne Mal, wenn die fliegen wollen, werden die einfach mal Stress haben.
Aber damit sagst du doch, dass wenn die Überwachung noch perfekter wäre, dass es dann ja funktionieren würde.
Aber das ist ein technisches Problem. Das geht einfach nicht, die Systeme 100 Prozent. Das ist der Grund, die Grundaussage der Biometrie ist, dass es nur Wahrscheinlichkeiten von Übereinstimmung gibt. Das heißt, es wird niemals eine 100-prozentige Übereinstimmung geben. Und da kannst du dich auf den Kopf stellen, das ist halt irgendwie die Grundaussage der Biometrie. Deswegen wird Biometrie niemals 100-prozentig vor Touristen schützen.
Eine Tür, eine dicke Tür beim Flugzeug, beim Piloten, ist jedem ungefähr sofort einsichtig, dass sie was bringt. Das ist eine einfache Maßnahme. Wieso die noch nicht früher eingeführt wurde, ist mir wie gesagt ein Rätsel. Diese Biometrie und diese FAD-Geschichten sind halt eine unglaublich komplexe, teure Maßnahme, die dann noch nicht mal am Ende Sicherheit bringt. Und wir können jetzt schon sagen, dass Biometrie immer umgehbar sein wird. Das Biometrie, also das BSI zum Beispiel hat sich nicht mal getraut, ihre eigenen Forschungsdaten zu publizieren, darüber, wie einfach Biometrie zu umgehen ist. Und deswegen kritisieren wir es halt, weil wir sagen, okay, das ist eine untaugliche, teure Maßnahme, die nicht mal mehr Sicherheit bringt.
Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf, Holger. Das ist nach langer Zeit endlich mal jemand, der sich getraut hat, hier auch mal Gegendruck aufzubauen.
Ansonsten vielleicht nochmal für alle zum Nachlesen. Wir haben unter www.ccc.de haben wir nochmal alle unsere Sachen zusammengetragen, was wir so an Informationen haben, was wir an Mitteilungen rausgegeben haben. Auch interessant die Anfragen, die wir an das BMI, an das Innenministerium gestellt haben und die Antworten dazu, die haben wir uns dann nochmal erlaubt zu kommentieren. Es war sehr amüsant. Und ja, da auch nochmal gern zum Nachlesen für alle.
Ihr Chaosradio 106, das Thema ist der elektronische Pass, der ab dem ersten November dieses Jahres eingeführt werden wird. Wir hören als nächstes die Nachrichten.
Verwöhnt, intelligent, raffiniert, sehr kalt.
Deutschland ist krass am Boden. Genau wie 45. Allen geht es voll schlecht, zu essen ist nicht und der Winter steht vor der Tür. Johnny Liebling, die Band aus Hamburg, bringt es auf den Punkt. Johnny Liebling, Sonntag bei KenFM, außerdem Martina Wimmer, Autoren des Buches, Champagner für alle.
Sie machen sich über mich lustig.
Komm vorbei, wenn du dazu noch in der Lage bist. Die Studios sind geheizt.
KenFM, die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Ken Jepsen.
Immer sonntags von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Live in den Fritz Studios in Potsdam Babelsberg. Und im Radio. Eine nach halb eins.
Fritz, Info.
Bei Mercedes in Deutschland fällt fast jeder 10. Arbeitsplatz weg. Daimler Chrysler will bei Mercedes im Laufe eines Jahres insgesamt 8.500 Jobs streichen. Der Konzern will den Stellenabbau vor allem durch Abfindungen erreichen. Der Bremer Bürgermeister Henning Scherff hat seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Scherff sagte, er werde in wenigen Wochen 67 und wolle noch ein Leben nach der Arbeit führen. Scherff wählte für seinen Rücktritt etwa die Mitte der Legislaturperiode. Union und SPD haben ihr zweites Sondierungsgespräch für eine mögliche Koalition geführt. Bundeskanzler Schröder sagte danach, er gehe davon aus, dass beide Seiten eine stabile Regierung für vier Jahre erreichen könnten. Es sei heute um Inhalte und nicht um Personalfragen gegangen. CDU-Chefin Merkel bezeichnete das Gespräch als ernsthaft und konstruktiv. Zum Sport in der Fußball Champions League trennten sich Schalke 04 und AC Mailand 2 zu 2 unentschieden. In der Nacht erwarten uns so gut wie keine Schauer und nur wenige Wolken, die tiefste Werte liegen zwischen 9 und 6 Grad. Am Tag ist es meistens wolkiger und es kann immer wieder mal regnen. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 13 bis 17 Grad. A10 nördlicher Berliner Ring, Hafenland Richtung Schwanebeck. Zwischen Kreuz Oranienburg und Birkenwerder gibt es eine Wande an der Baustelle, die den linken Fahrstreifen blockiert. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring, Hafenland Richtung Werder. Zwischen Tankstelle Wolfslacke West und Falkensee wird die Fahrbahn erneuert. Der linke Fahrstreifen ist dort geschwärzt. Ansonsten überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Mario Bartsch, drei Minuten und halb eins.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Hey!
Wunderbare Musikauswahl vom Kollegen Rosengard, die heute Abend im Blumen. Das Chaosradio 106, der elektronische Pass, ist das Thema der Sendung heute. Und mal abgesehen davon, dass das Biometrie, wie wir eben gelernt haben, sowieso nicht hundertprozentig sicher ist. Und von den ganzen technischen Unwägbarkeiten, die da mitkommen, gibt es dann auch noch die soziokulturelle Komponente, die eigentlich auch immer wieder nicht bedacht wird und die hat der Sven ins Spiel zu bringen.
Ja, hallo. Ja, ich fand eigentlich auch die Frage von dir vorhin richtig zu fragen, wie viel Repression ist denn angemessen? Natürlich kann man jetzt überlegen, wie viel Sicherheit wollen wir eigentlich und welche Maßnahmen sollen dazu passieren? Aber mit dem elektronischen Reisepass sind wir ja schon eigentlich ziemlich weit vorgeprescht und ich finde es in vieler Hinsicht ebenfalls bedenklich, dass man das so macht. Weil zum Beispiel die Tatsache, dass er zum ersten Mal, so wie ich es jedenfalls verstanden habe, auch elektronisch auszulesen ist, ohne mein Wissen, finde ich schon ein ziemlich starkes Stück. Weil bisher habe ich einen Reisepass immer vorlegen müssen und dann wusste ich, jetzt wird er ausgelesen sozusagen von dem entsprechenden Person, die ihn dann gesehen hat.
Wir können dich beruhigen, das hatten wir ganz am Anfang der Sendung.
Ja, also zumindestens im Moment ist es politisch nicht gewollt und deswegen hat sich das BSI, die diese Spezifikation machen, haben gesagt, ne, also wir haben eine technische Maßnahme, die verhindern soll, dass man ihn unbemerkt auslesen kann. Du musst ihn also jetzt vorher optisch einlesen und diese Maschinenlesbare Zeile und kannst dann erst über ein Kryptographeles-Protokoll mit dem Chip sprechen.
Man muss mich sozusagen um Einwilligung fragen, dann wenn ich diesen Pass habe, um letztendlich das auslesen zu können, oder?
So ist das gedacht, ob es dann technisch nachher wirklich auch alles so ist. Das werden wir dann sehen, wenn die Pässe da sind, aber so ist es auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal vorgesehen.
Aber umgekehrt, bemerken könnte ich es auch nicht, wenn es jetzt doch ausgelesen wäre.
Richtig, genau. Das kannst du nicht bemerken.
Und was ich auch generell sehr tragisch dabei finde, ist ja eigentlich, dass wenn ich biometrische Daten da drin habe in diesem Pass, dass ja eigentlich genau das, was auch vorher mal gesagt wird, eigentlich in die Gesamtbevölkerung unter Generalverdacht gestellt wird, weil es wird ja erstmal verdächtigt sozusagen. Ich habe dann ein Merkmal und kann es dann später eventuell bei entsprechenden Vorfällen nochmal vergleichen oder gucken, ob es dann das war.
Das ist in der Konsequenz eine Umkehr der Unschuldsvermutung. Damit eine Aushebelung, ein aushebelndes Rechtsstaat. Weil der Rechtsstaat basiert auf der Unschuldsvermutung unter anderem.
Ja genau, das sehe ich teilweise auch bei diesem Pass letztendlich, weil es ja wie das im Vorort mich eigentlich für schuldig erklärt. Und es ist halt schwierig. Also wie gesagt, ich finde es auch sehr bedenklich und genauso im Grunde genommen wie der Gesundheitswesen ist jetzt zwar ein anderes Thema, aber es ist ja ähnlich. Letztendlich, wo auch bestimmte Daten später gespeichert werden sollen, die ebenfalls persönlich sind, sag ich mal, und wo ich auch nicht mehr sicher gehen kann, werden sie dann von mir ausgelesen ohne meine Einwilligung.
Wird das eigentlich eine RFID-Karte auch?
Na, da ist ja das Problem, dass die Daten halt zentral gespeichert werden. Also sie denken gerade über so ganz komische, krude Sachen nach irgendwie den Patienten CDs mitzugeben, wo ihre Daten drauf sind. Aber prinzipiell wird es halt darauf hinauslaufen, dass du halt irgendwie die Karte hast mit einer ID und in einer zentralen Datenbank dann deine Krankengeschichte liegen wird.
Interessantes Detail zu den Pässen ist übrigens, dass die Schweizer sich entschieden haben, die biometrischen Reisepässe freiwillig zu machen. Das heißt also man muss sozusagen sagen, ich will so einen Denkabend, so einen biometrischen Pass mit Chip, ansonsten kriegt man den normalen alten.
Ja, mit den RFID-Chips da fühle ich mich auch schon verfolgt. Ich habe letztens schon mal einen Joghurtbrecher verdächtigt, RFID-Chip zu enthalten. Es war zwar keiner, aber dennoch, man wird ja langsam ein bisschen...
Wobei wir also auch mal klarmachen möchten, dass wir, was diese Reisepässe betrifft, möchten wir also nicht zu sehr auf dieser RFID die Technologie rumreiten. Also die Idee, dass man da keine Kontakte hat, die halt irgendwie nach dreimal reinstecken irgendwie abgelutscht sind oder da irgendwelche Kaugummis in den Lesegeräten kleben.
Das sind keine Argumente. Also die würden Lesezyklen von mehreren Zehntausenden überstehen. Das heißt, was du normal an Grenzkontrollgängen machen würdest, würden die auf jeden Fall überlegen.
Der passt schon, aber nicht das Lesegerät.
Also ich finde, ich kann nicht übereinstimmen. Ich finde den Einsatz von der FAD in diesen Reisepassen vollständig sinnlos und zweckfrei. Weil es gibt genügend technologische Alternativen, die auch hinreichend erprobt sind. Es gibt irgendwie optische Möglichkeiten.
Man hätte einen Barcode machen können oder so Sachen. Genau.
Es gibt irgendwie holographische Speichermethoden, 2D-Barcodes, Chipkarten und so weiter und so fort, die wesentlich weniger riskant sind, die irgendwie wesentlich einfacher zu realisieren werden, wesentlich preiswerter werden. Und das wird halt nicht gemacht, sondern das wird halt eine komplexe Synnose, nicht getestete Technologie eingeführt, um die Industrie zu fördern.
Es sieht auch so aus, als wenn es irgendwie versteckt werden sollte, weil es ja in diesem Umschlag letztendlich eigentlich nicht sichtbar ist, diese Maßnahme, sag ich mal. Und von daher fand ich auch schon sehr, sehr verdeckt.
Sie haben ein Zeichen außen drauf, das sagt, irgendwie dort ist ein Funkchip drinne und das ist einfach die logische Konsequenz, das irgendwo zu verstecken, also irgendwo einzubringen. Also das ist wahrscheinlich...
Das Auge reißt ja mit.
Das ist nicht gewollt, dass es jetzt nicht gesehen wird und sie kennzeichnet es auch. Also das kann man wirklich nicht zum Vorwurf machen.
Naja, also gegenüber dem Barcode, den hätte man natürlich gleich auch selber erkannt, sag ich mal. Aber klar, so durch extra Kennzeichnung wahrscheinlich auch. Aber es ist doch schon ein bisschen anders, klar. Nee, aber insgesamt, wie gesagt, ich finde es auch bedenklich, dass man da solche Sachen einführt, also beziehungsweise in der Form einführt. Und die Diskussion hat ja auch eigentlich vorher oder klar, muss ja nicht stattfinden. Man hat sich einfach, wie gesagt, auf ein ziemlich hohes Level gesetzt und gesagt, wir wollen diese Sicherheitsstufe und führen jetzt so ein Pass mit diesen Merkmalen ein.
Wobei es auch im Vergleich zu anderen Projekten wird hier schon relativ offen gearbeitet. Also das ist so, dass diese ganzen Spezifikationen und Entwürfe zumindestens fachöffentlich, also das heißt, sind dann auf den Web-Servern, bei der ICHO kann man die Sachen runterladen. Das ist schon mal eigentlich eine gute Sache. Also das hat uns jetzt auch sehr geholfen. Die Sache wirklich auch zu betrachten, auch jetzt technisch wirklich mal ins Detail gehen zu können, anstatt immer nur irgendwelche Black Boxes zu reden. Also vorausgesetzt, dass es auch tatsächlich so umgesetzt wird, wie es in den Spezifikationen immer steht mit der Einschränkung. Aber allein die Tatsache, dass auch so Sachen wie Krypto-Algorithmen diskutiert werden und so was, das ist schon mal, finde ich schon mal einen Fortschritt.
Auf der anderen Seite sind aber irgendwie, werden Studienergebnisse zurückgehalten. Und wie gerade halt diese BiOP-2-Studie, da sind halt nicht nur die Überwendungstests, die halt nicht öffentlich zugänglich sind, sondern irgendwie sämtliche Anhänge gibt es nicht mehr. Also sie wurden halt explizit aus der Version rausgenommen. Und wie alle Vermerker auf die Anhänge gibt es halt in der aktuellen Version, die halt veröffentlicht wurde, gibt es nicht mehr. Wo halt irgendwie sämtliche Fakten, also die eigentlichen Zahlen von den Testergebnissen irgendwie drinstehen.
Also man kann es einfach so zusammenfassen beim Thema. Einfach die sind die staatlichen Behörden wesentlich auskunftsfreudiger und sagen wir mit Dokumentationsbereiter als beim Thema Biometrie, was einfach damit zusammenhängt, dass sie sich da ein bisschen sicherer fühlen und dass halt die Technologie auf einem relativ hohen Sicherheitsniveau implementiert ist. Problem bei FID ist halt, dass niemand über die Langzeithaltbarkeit wirklich Bescheid weiß. Beim Thema Biometrie hingegen sieht es halt alles so aus wie Vertuschung, Verdeckung, sie wissen, dass es nicht funktioniert und versuchen es halt irgendwie trotzdem durchzudrücken. Also so fühlt sich das halt an, so was jetzt so die Reaktion von den Behörden betrifft und auch wenn man so mit dem BSI redet, dann sagen die halt, naja, wir machen halt die Koptografie und wir machen mit der FID, aber bitte, bitte zwingen uns nicht dazu, irgendwas zur Biometrie zu sagen, weil das ist nicht unser Job.
Also es gibt einfach mal irgendwie klare Fakten, so was wie nicht erfassbare Fingerabdrücke von zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung oder Gesichtserkennung mit normalerweise, also wenn man schon gut rechnet, Fehlerraten von 15 Prozent und man muss einfach mal auf die Bevölkerungsdicht, also auf die Bevölkerungszahl hochrechnen. Das sind halt wirklich mehrere hunderttausend, die es betreffen wird. Na, das digitale Gesichtsbild ist ein biometrisches Datum eigentlich. Interessanterweise dabei ist, dass halt ehemals davon ausgegangen wurde, dass zum ersten November eine automatische Gesichtserkennung stattfinden wird. Und da sind sie halt irgendwie auch ganz klamm und heimlich zurückgerudert und führen jetzt wirklich nur das Bild ein und diese ganze wirklich automatische Überprüfung der Gesichtsgeometrie findet halt nicht statt. Und zwar aus dem Grund, weil die Technik halt einfach noch nicht in der Lage ist, das zu tun. Also spätestens ab 2007, wenn der Fingerabdruck drin ist, dann müssen sie halt technisch irgendwie den Abgleich machen, weil es geht halt nur noch technisch. Aber also für für Gesicht vermute ich ja mal fast, dass es halt nie wirklich funktionieren wird mit der Technik.
Also die derzeitige Software ist halt auf einem Stand, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass sie erst mal als Überbrücken einfach nur das Bild aus dem Pass auslesen und das nehmendes Bild, was man halt auch so auf dem Pass sehen kann, hält und dann nochmal als drittes Bild denjenigen, der da rumsteht hat, was ja schon mal ein Sicherheitsgewinn eigentlich ist.
Mal ernsthaft, also sie können auch halt auf den Pass gucken. Boulevardeske Frage hinterher so. Was können wir dagegen tun, dass wir uns, also ich meine, wir wählen Leute, wir wählen die Leute, die uns dann mit solchen Zeug verarschen. Gibt es irgendwelche integeren Bundestagsmitglieder, mit denen man da noch vernünftig drüber reden kann?
Der Bundestag hat die Sache nur durchgewunken.
Ja klar, aber es muss doch da irgendwo...
In einer Art und Weise, die wirklich skandalös ist.
Irgendwo müssen da doch ein paar Menschen sitzen. Ich meine da sitzen immerhin 650, 60 Abgeordnete rum. Da müsste auch eine Handvoll Leute sein, die über so viel Grips verfügen, dass sie nicht alles mit sich machen.
Das ist ungefähr eine Handvoll, das stimmt.
Wen sprechen wir da an?
Willst du einen Namen haben oder? Wir haben Kontakt zu Politikern aus mehreren Parteien und die sind auch unser Meinung. Das Problem ist halt einfach, dass gerade was die interne Diskussion bei der SPD betrifft, Schili halt dermaßen lernresistent ist. Also sie haben versucht, ihn davon zu überzeugen, dass es halt scheiße ist, aber er halt irgendwie cholerische Anfälle gekriegt hat und sagt, ich will das jetzt aber haben.
Das ist vielleicht ist er einfach zu alt.
Alterssinnilität.
So weit würde ich nicht gehen, aber wir kennen das alles von unseren Vätern, oder? Gut, vielen Dank Sven.
Ja, ich fand es trotzdem gut oder finde es gut, dass er dieses Thema trotzdem behandelt, weil es ist wie gesagt sonst eigentlich kaum in der Diskussion und ich finde es schon sehr, sehr wichtig.
Man müsste es eigentlich in die Diskussion heben, indem man überall irgendwo mal anrufen, seine Meinung sagen darf, ungefragt auf dieses Thema kommt. Das wäre eigentlich mal was ganz Hübsches. Also ab 1 Uhr beim Deutschlandradio zum Beispiel. Noch was, die Kosten. Also hast du ja eben schon mal kurz angerissen. Was kostet der ganze Kram eigentlich? Haben wir da irgendwie eine Summe?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Danke.
Es gibt Zahlen, die kursieren, die sind allerdings schon ein bisschen älter. Es gibt ein Büro für Technikfolgenabschätzung am Bundestag, die sich mit solchen Sachen, also Grundsatzfragen beschäftigen. Und die haben mal vor drei Jahren ungefähr Zahlen ins Spiel gebracht, wo sie von einer Einführung von ungefähr 700 Millionen Euro rechnen.
Und jährliche Kosten von weiteren 600 Millionen.
Seit 600 Millionen Kosten. So, das war aber erstmal ganz grob, bevor überhaupt feststand, was überhaupt eigentlich gemacht wird. Da gab es nur so die diffuse Idee, die haben mehrere Szenarien durchgespielt, den kann man auch einsehen, den Bericht, der ist öffentlich. Sie haben also mehrere Szenarien durchgespielt. Wir haben jetzt die Situation, dass wir in Deutschland für die neuen Reisepässe ab 1. November 59 Euro bezahlen. Wir haben die Situation, dass wir in der Schweiz und Großbritannien ungefähr das 3- oder fast 4-fache dafür bezahlen.
Also in der Schweiz kostet es 250 Franken.
Das sind ungefähr 160 Euro.
Und da kommen wir auch so langsam so in den Bereich, wo man sagen kann, okay, damit decken sie vielleicht eventuell Kosten. Also was sie in Deutschland halt tun ist, sie geben den Pass halt für 60 Euro raus, damit decken sie vielleicht die Herstellungskosten, aber so den gesamten bürokratischen Aufwand, die gesamten Lesegeräte werden halt hintenrum aus irgendwelchen anderen Töpfen, so zum Beispiel vom BGS, also steuern die halt trotzdem Dubit im Endeffekt.
Interessant sagt das BMI dazu, sie werden im Rahmen von Ersatzbeschaffung angeschafft. Also muss man sich so vorstellen, bisher steht da halt irgendwie so ein Lesegerät, so ein kleiner Scanner für diese Reisepässe und ein PC, der dann halt die Daten anzeigt. Und sie wollen jetzt also die Fingerabdruckscanner, die RFID-Lesegeräte und vor allem auch die Gesichtserkennung mit der gesamten Vermessung, wollen sie jetzt im Rahmen von Ersatzbeschaffungen.
Das ist schon Wahnsinn, wie sich Hardwarepreise so ratzfatz halbieren über die Jahre immer, ist so unglaublich.
Genau, dazu kommt natürlich das sogenannte Enrollment. Enrollment ist der Fachbegriff dafür, also das Ausrollen, also sprich das Erfassen, die Antragstellung bei der Meldestelle. Du gehst hin, gibst dann wieder dein Foto, das wird irgendwie eingescannt, dein Fingerabdruck wird abgenommen und so was. Diese ganzen Sachen müssen ja auch gemacht werden. Dazu kommt, dass wir im Moment bei uns in Deutschland ein Foto abgeben. Das heißt, ich kann da auch im Prinzip erstmal alles abgeben, weil die keine Möglichkeit haben, das vor Ort zu kontrollieren.
Ob das Foto wirklich dir entspricht?
Richtig, also auf den ersten Blick mag es so aussehen, aber bei dieser Gesichtserkennung, das sind ja alles winzig kleine, es geht ja wirklich um Millimeter, die wir da haben. Und wenn ich jetzt ein Foto, ich kann ja ein Digitalfoto auch digital ausbelichten lassen, irgendwo bei Rossmann oder Aldi oder sonst irgendwo und kann es dann auch als Foto wieder abgeben. Das heißt, ich kann mich mit Photoshop im Prinzip ran setzen und mein Auge drei Pixel nach links verschieben, die Nase zwei Pixel nach unten und dann werde ich ganz, ganz viel Spaß in Zukunft bei den Grenzkontrollen haben.
Oder halt genau, keinen Spaß.
Tja und wenn Heugi sich mal eine andere Brille kauft, dann wird er auch viel Spaß haben.
Ich habe eben überlegt, wenn du dir eine Glatze rasierst, den Bart abrasierst und dir die Augenbrauen ein bisschen heller färbst, dann gehen wir beide und ein Bild von mir abgibst, das haut hin. Und einfach nur sagst du, ich habe ein bisschen abgenommen.
Du musst noch ein bisschen abnehmen, Heugi.
Nein, ich meine, dann sagst du einfach, das ist jetzt ein paar Monate alt, ich habe eben was abgenommen. Aber das war es dann noch.
Jetzt müssen wir vielleicht einen kleinen Exkurs in Richtung Gesichtsversmessung machen, aber dafür reicht die Zeit jetzt nicht mehr.
Ganz kurz, also das Problem ist eigentlich, dass die Daten auf dem Personal zehn Jahre gültig sind und keiner kann wirklich davon ausgehen, dass du halt zehn Jahre lang dein Gesicht so behältst, wie irgendwie zur Zeit der Antragstellung.
Wenn ich zehn Kilo abnehme, ist das Doppelkinn weg, dann hast du schon mal...
Bart stehen lassen und schon wird kein System mehr funktionieren. Also bei der BIP-2-Studie war halt so der interessante Fakt, dass 97 Prozent der Falschidentifikation halt irgendwie eine Brille, also so eine schwarze Hornbrille getragen haben. Das heißt, da sieht man halt mal wo drauf die Algorithmen Wert legen. Das heißt, wenn du keine Brille mehr hast, sondern irgendwie dann Kontaktlinsen, dann kommst du halt einfach mal nicht mehr an der Grenze vorbei.
Ganz einfach, Brillen werden verboten, Bärte werden verboten, dann haben wir das Problem gelöst.
Gesichter werden verboten.
Gesichter werden verboten. Der Peter hat angerufen und Peter, du sagst, wir entwickeln uns zum Polizeistaat. Glaubst du wirklich?
Ich habe damals wirklich kopf und kragen riskiert, damit der DDR-Steuer weggekommen ist.
Inwiefern?
Ich habe später erfahren vorgesehen für eine Internierungslager und Solidierung. Und wenn ich sehe, was hier los ist, der Mielke würde sich tod freuen. Das hat er nicht geschafft.
Also was ist denn bei uns los? Was ist in der recht jungen 15 Jahre alten BRD los, was es in der DDR nicht gab, worüber Mielke sich freuen würde?
Die hatten zum Beispiel nicht diese Kameras, um alles zu erfassen. Die hatten auch Kameras, die waren ziemlich groß, die konnte jeder sehen. Heute wird ja nur bekannt, wo eine Kamera ist, wenn man sie sieht.
Ich habe heute auf der A9 eine Kamera stehen, die stand da einfach, mitten drin. Keine Brücke, kein gar nichts. Und habe mich gefragt, was filmt diese Kamera eigentlich?
Die gesamten Autobahnen um Frankfurt rum sind in Abständen von ein paar hundert Metern, überall Kameras.
Ich habe überlegt, wenn ich da morgen wieder lang fahre, einfach mal ran zu fahren, das Ding umzutreten und mal gucken, mal gucken, wer kommt.
Ja, aber ich meine, die sind genau das Gleiche. Du hast halt da die Kameras und du hast es auch noch bezahlt mit deinen Steuergeldern, dass die dort Kameras zu deinen Überwachungen aufstellen.
In Thüringen hatten wir hier schon einen Fall in Weimar, die mussten die Kameras wieder abnehmen und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, das sind aber solche Fälle.
Aber mit diesem Fingerabdruck, es ist einfach lächerlich. Was nicht lächerlich ist. Ich glaube, es laufen Sachen, da wissen nicht mal die Leute im Bundestag davon.
Wieso ist das lächerlich mit den Fingerabdrücken?
Menschenskind. Einfach der Aufwand. Und wenn ich meinen Pass oder meinen Ausweis habe und da ist mein Fingerabdruck drauf. Ja gut, da ist mein Fingerabdruck drauf. Aber es laufen ja noch viele, viele andere Sachen. Ich weiß zum Beispiel aus guter Quelle, dass wie zu DDR-Zeiten auch wieder Geruchsproben gesammelt werden. Und davon hört kein Mensch was.
Hat da irgendwie der Anwesenden hier im Studio schon mal was von gehört?
Na ja, also prinzipiell von dem DDR-Programm dazu, das hier durchaus durch die Presse gegangen, aber das, dass es jetzt wieder passieren soll. Wäre mir neu, aber ich meine gut im Zeitalter von DNA-Spuren ist das halt im Zweifel auch auch redundant.
Und ich denke da laufen Sachen, da wissen nicht mal Leute im Bundestag was das ist. Wenn die das wüssten, dann würden sie es nicht wurschen.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Also es geht um die Geruchsspuren.
Ach so, die Geruchsspuren.
Die Geruchsspuren und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, jeder kann ja schon über GBS überwacht werden.
Über GBS.
Kann jeder überwacht werden? Nee. Also da machst du dich nochmal schlauter und rufst du wieder an. Wir sind ja am Ende der Sendung angelangt, okay? Peter, gute Nacht, danke dir. Haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen? Jede Menge Ankündigungen natürlich, ich meine jetzt inhaltlich.
Genau, wir waren auf jeden Fall nochmal auf unseren Kongress, den Chaos Communication Kongress hinweisend, der zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr stattfindet, Weihnachten und Silvester, BCC am Alexanderplatz. Ja, was gibt es da zu sehen? Vorträge, Workshops, Informationen zum Thema E-Pass auch, was wir heute hatten, Biometrie, RFID, Internet-Sicherheit, viele bunte Sachen. Was haben wir da? Videoinstallationen gibt es zu sehen. Es ist ein buntes Programm. Schaut nach unter www.ccc.de. Wir haben speziell für den elektronischen Reisepass, worüber wir heute Abend gesprochen haben, eine Seite eingerichtet. Das ist www.ccc.de. Ihr könnt uns eine E-Mail schreiben, wenn ihr Fragen habt oder uns noch Sachen beitragen wollt. Chaosradio.ccc.de. Und es gibt morgen eine Veranstaltung von der Humanistischen Union zum Thema elektronischer Reisepassung, biometrische Erfassung. Das ist um 19 Uhr im Haus der Demokratie und Menschenrechte in der Greifswalder Straße 4.
Und ihr könnt vielleicht versuchen, nein nicht vielleicht versuchen, ihr solltet bitteschön versuchen, dabei mitzuhelfen, dass dieses Thema in die öffentliche Diskussion gelangt. Insbesondere die Boulevardmedien haben sich dazu überragend noch nicht verhalten. Vielleicht einige Fachzeitschriften oder Qualitätsmedien, wie auch immer man sie nennen will. Aber das reicht lange nicht aus. Also beteiligt euch. Es gibt sicherlich die ein oder andere auch subversive Möglichkeit, auch mal tagsüber in einem Radio oder in einem Medium eine Antwort zu geben, die zu einer Frage passt, die nie gestellt wurde. Aber Hauptsache, dass irgendwie mal ein Bewusstsein geschaffen wird. Ich bin mir ganz zuversichtlich, dass ihr das hinkriegt. Ihr seid schließlich Fritz-Öhrer.
Und die alten Reisepässe gibt's noch. Ihr könnt sie noch bekommen bis ungefähr Mitte Oktober 20. oder so schätzen wir mal. Aber beeilt euch auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr die alten noch haben wollt, ohne Chip, ohne Biometrie.
Das war Chaosradio 106.
Also der Pass ist dann weiterhin noch gültig. Ihr könnt damit irgendwie trotzdem in die USA einreisen für die nächsten zehn Jahre beziehungsweise fünf Jahre, wenn ihr unter 26 seid.
Und das überhaupt wollt. Das war Chaosradio 106. Es ging um den elektronischen Reisepass ab November. Wie gesagt, wird er eingeführt. Das nächste Chaosradio, also Chaosradio 107, gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im Oktober. Das ist der 26. Oktober ab 22 Uhr, dann wieder auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz. Es geht um 1 Uhr weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Der Frank wollte noch ein Wort loslegen.
Und zwar nicht vergessen Ende Dezember wieder der Chaos Communication Kongress in Berlin am BCC. Schon mal darauf vorbereiten, Kalender eintragen.
Der 26. Dezember ist übrigens ein Montag, damit ihr das schon mal irgendwie jetzt so in eurem Universum. Also weil da müsste es losgehen dann eigentlich. 27.
Genau, diesmal vier Tage bis zum 30. Damit es auch keine Ausrede gibt, wo man Silvester noch groggy ist.
Alles klar. Vielen Dank Frank, vielen Dank Frank, vielen Dank Starbuck. Es gibt ab 1 Uhr den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Mein Name ist Holger Klein. Ich danke für die Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht.